Hello, everybody.
April Fool's.
The screen.
We're so back.
Hello.
Today, I'm a little naked today.
What is this knife I'm holding?
I'm making a salad.
What do you mean?
I'm my true form.
Also, my brain today.
I just need you guys to know.
I had four hours.
of sleep.
Maybe.
My brain's a little bit more enhanced than usual.
I might be a little more stupid than usual because, like, I
had, like, three to four hours of sleep today because I was
working.
I spent my entire night.
I went to bed at, like, 9 a.m.
today.
And then, yes, today.
I went to bed at 9 a.m.
today.
And then, like, I woke up at What time did I woke up?
12?
At like 12 or 1?
So my brain is not okay.
But that's fine.
Today's the best day to not be okay.
It's April Fool's.
If I do something fucked up, I can be like, Ha ha, April
Fool's.
That's not me.
That's not my intrusive thoughts thinking.
I'm just joking with you guys.
April Fool's.
You'll never know what is right or wrong So yes, my brain
currently Might need a little bit more oxygen today But I
sort of like fucked up with that So right now I'm actually
on a stream of consciousness Or I don't even thinking about
what I'm saying And oh god, this is not a good idea Usually
I have I know it's really fucking wild this little filter on
like a little you know a little like you know don't be a
brand risk filter you know like you're you're a you're
you're an internet personality now dokey don't say anything
that you will regret but today today is a little risky when
there's not enough oxygen going to my brain It is um, it is
a little risky right now for me to stream because I only I
did not have a lot of sleep So we'll see how this goes.
We're gonna see how this goes, but it's okay.
It's okay.
Where are you gonna do?
What are you gonna do?
Cancel a tomato?
I'm a fucking fruit.
You can't do that to me.
Anyway, yes, happy April Fool's everybody.
I hope you guys
you guys enjoyed uh welcoming back our intro it was it's
finally here i know like april i could have just played the
intro for an hour straight but i sort of actually really
wanted to play the murder of sonic the hedgehog it's been
like a game that i wanted to play since last year so like i
was like you know what i was so i was so sad i was actually
waiting to like you know because like Japan is really really
good with like April Fool's and So I was like oh wait cuz
like they released cuz you know Japan really goes like all
out when it comes to like April Fool's pranks for some
reason I don't know why I don't know why but like it's
always Japan that does like like pull all stops and does
like a hundred percent On April Fool's jokes, you know like
people in America They don't try as hard as Japan Like,
like, Japan will make, like, actual, like, I was so scared.
Kerala finally announced, like, a new season, but I couldn't
even tell if it was real.
I was like, please don't be April Fool's.
Please don't be a sick April Fool's joke.
Because they've done this before.
They will release, like, fully animated trailers and just be
like, Kiki, April Fool's.
I swear, they've done it.
They did it for Panty and Star.
I remember they did it for Panty and Star.
before they actually announced like they did that before for
Pantheon stocking and it hurt it actually hurt so much so I
couldn't tell I couldn't tell so like anyway um before I
posted my schedule I was actually waiting to see if like
Japan was gonna release anything similar to the murder of
Sonic the Hedgehog so I can be like so I could I could be
like I could be like I could be like, okay, I could get in
on this.
The FOMO.
Flavor of the Month.
I could get in on the April Fool's flavor of the month if
they released another game on April Fool's.
But they didn't.
They didn't release anything new.
I was so sad.
I was like, oh my God.
No April Fool's flavor of the month.
What is this?
How would we stream or survive without our regularly
released content.
Oh my god.
We need new content.
But it's okay.
It's okay.
I haven't played the murder of Sonic the Hedgehog.
So it's almost new for all of us.
It's almost new.
The real April 4th.
No fucking free games to play on April 4th.
How is this possible?
So yes, anyway, Maddie, thank you for the super chat, thank
you, thank you, I had a ratatouille flashback moment with
the intro, thank you, thank you, thank you, don't worry
guys, um, in two hours, I think I scheduled it for two
hours, uh, the, uh, the, the full intro will be uploaded as
a video, so do not, oh my god, Sonic!
The game was actually developed by the social team.
Oh my god!
America!
Fuck yeah!
Oh my god!
If I can get fact checked by anybody, I'm happy with Sonic
the Hedgehog.
I'm so...
Sonic the Hedgehog!
Where is my sequel?
What happened?
The Sega of America!
I'm happy that you know what I'm not upset that I got like
um actually because I got um who else all right who else
could have got um actually by the official Sonic the
Hedgehog though come on I wear that pride I wear that with
honor I don't worry
what happened sonic did you guys peeped you guys fell off no
oh my god anyway i'm super i'm super duper excited to
finally play i have like no um i have like no actual like
knowledge of whatever this game is the only thing i know
about this game is that I saw a screenshot of like Sonic
doing the Yamcha pose so like that is like literally my only
like point of knowledge for this game okay and then I looked
at the also by the way how's the sound by the way um is the
is the sound okay that's actually crazy though oh my god
Sonic I can't believe the official Sonic team is here
watching a tomato play this game a year late by the way okay
so like i know it's not just a visual novel because um i was
looking okay let's see if my sound guys awake uh all right
they're not in my chat so i said they're not awake oh and
they are they are in my chat okay i know that there's more
to this because i looked at assist mode and why the fuck is
there in this in invincibility and uh invincibility and then
remove pitfalls and I was like oh this is not a regular this
is not a regular visual novel I was just like this is what
do you mean pitfalls what does this mean this is not a
regular this is there's a journalist mode why is there a
journalist mode Anyway, um, yes, don't mind a knife.
I'm just making my salad.
So, um, if anybody, like, uh, if anybody gets stabbed, they,
it wasn't my fault.
They walked into it, okay?
Like, okay, I'm just saying if I start walking around,
extending my arm out, holding a knife, and, like, I just
walk forward, is it really my fault if somebody else walks
into my knife?
Is it really my fault?
I would say that like it would be an act It was like their
fault for being stupid enough to walk into my knife Okay
guys like how is that my fault like they could just you know
They could just like walk the other way like oh my god just
turn around What is that red stain it's just tomato sauce
You know I was just making a salad all right Anyway let's
let's fucking play the murder of Sonic the Hedgehog Phew,
made it on the train 15 minutes ahead of schedule So far so
good for my first day on the job Oh, I totally forgot my
name tag Isn't ready yet, I should make Wait, is that me?
Is that my Sonic OC?
I'll just sign my name here Oh my god!
Oh my god, he's red too, just like me How did they know?
I can't believe it.
That's my official Sonic OC, guys.
Um, okay.
Doki FPS, VTuber, TTV.
Oh, wait.
Uh, okay.
Doki, FPS, VTuber.
Okay, there you go.
That feels better.
All right.
See, I thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Doki, I passed my PhD today.
Let's go!
Real night.
April fools.
Thank you for confirming.
Thank you, but the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Doki Mado.
Oh my god, you're right.
I need people to know I'm a VTuber.
I need like Doki Mado FPS VTuber.
There we go.
I need people to know I'm a VTuber.
Hey.
Doki Mado FPS VTuber.
Did I spell that right?
Yeah.
Yes.
Oh my god, that's me.
Hope passengers can read my scribble.
believe it.
I'm an official Sonic OC.
Dining car.
Uh-oh.
Am I nervous?
Is this first day on the job jitters?
Working the train's dining car can be so... See?
This is why I have a knife.
I'm a chef.
Come on, Tokimido VFPS VTube.
Shake it off.
Slap.
Tokimido FPS V...
Okay.
Maybe it was a bad idea.
You had to have an incredibly long name.
Dokey Mado FPS VTube.
Did I just see you hitting yourself?
Mr. Conductor, sir.
How are you doing this morning?
Oh, quite all right myself.
Though feeling a little bit bittersweet.
Is that because you're...
Guys, guys, I need a promotion.
Okay.
I have a family.
to feed.
The family is me.
Oh, trying to butter me up on the very first day, are we?
Alas, today is my last day as the conductor.
I'm retiring after 32 wonderful years.
Time for me and the Mirage Express to say goodbye to one
another.
Oh, congratulations on retirement, sir.
My wife is...
Oh, he has a...
No, it's okay.
I can be the...
The trading side.
Very excited about it.
She's already got our plane tickets to Spagonia Unlocked.
Oh, locked.
Our shower's been on the fritz.
So I'm excited to use the hotels.
Ha ha.
I can see why his wife's excited.
Enough of my...
quibbles today is your first day working the dining car
here's the menu for today menu added to your inventory oh i
got the menu i can open up the inventory at any time to see
what's on that menu it features chili dog instant ramen and
chicken cordon i like how instant ramen is in there it looks
so fancy imagine eating like instant ramen at such a fancy
vip there's a fucking Chandelier.
How is there like a chandelier in this fucking...
Like, in this train.
I don't know.
I feel like having a chandelier on a moving train seems
incredibly fucking dangerous.
Why do you look so nervous?
All we have on the train is a microwave.
Ha-ha-ha-ha.
Though, I'm sure a little quiz is in order.
A quiz?
which of these do we serve in the dining car oh chicken oh i
read okay guys for april fools the biggest joke right now is
that i can read ding ding ding glad you can read the menu
okay a little about the vessel this is a state of the art
high speed smart train with all the latest gadgets.
The train can really handle anything you throw at it, but
yet we serve instant ramen?
We've had a lot of ventures together.
Me and this train.
It's not easy to leave.
After 32 years, I don't blame him for being wistful.
This train is exclusively used for events.
It's not a passenger train.
all the but no all the budget went to the fucking chandelier
imagine eating instant ramen with champagne and chandeliers
i remember that from the interview what's the event today a
murder mystery party wait you mean sonic isn't actually dead
i got clickbaited sonic team
i can't believe he's not actually dead What's the point?
What is...
Nothing better than some thrillers to end my tenure as
conducted.
Guests will be funneled here to the dining car as a home
base, so to speak.
I'll be with you to gather tickets, but after that, you'll
be on your own.
So I'll need you to do everything in your power to make sure
you're safe.
make sure our paying guests are well taken care of.
I can't afford to lose my job.
This is all I have left.
You sure can't.
The severance pay is lousy.
Voa-ha-ha-ha.
Doors to the Mirage Express are opening.
All aboard!
I can't believe Sonic is actually still alive.
I know!
What?
the fuck what's the point why did that bring a knife for
that's so messed up oh Amy wow oh sorry wait wow this train
is incredible what fascinating tech I forgot what vector
sounds like he's a he's a gator you're right devs I could
get used to staying on a train like this.
What do you expect?
You know, I always go all out for my birthday party.
Oh, shit.
Um.
Guys, I could never do like Rouge justice.
This train is as elegant as you are.
Amy.
I can't promise I won't take anything, though.
Oh, wait, shit.
Fuck, there's so many voices.
Guys, I can't keep up to date with all these voices.
Um, whoa, calm down there, Rouge.
Did I not just catch you stealing from the train station
gift shop?
Howdy.
That was my best country accent.
It was a pen, knucklehead.
Who's gonna miss me?
A teeny tiny pen.
What cast of characters am I stuck with?
Get a hold of yourself.
Doki made a FPS V-tube.
You're sweating through your uniform.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
It's the star.
It's him.
Are you still here?
That's you!
Oh my god!
That's him!
Okay, the main character!
Um, wait, let me get into the...
Let me get into the mindset.
Chili dogs, chili dogs.
Hey pal, can't get one of those chili dogs?
They're both the same answer.
What a lovely day to be.
alive and not dead.
This is an illusion of choice.
It's literally the same answer.
Okay, radio friend.
Well, aren't you friendly?
Why can't I be normal for one second?
Sonic, wait until I announce everyone's rules to get food.
Sorry about that birthday, girl.
I'll be coming around to collect everyone's tick that's
almost a tick tocks I'll be I'll be coming here oh my god
what's wrong with me I'll be coming around to collect
everyone's tickets please have them out and ready you'll
join me doki madeo fpsv tube won't you just click on whoever
you'd like to talk with and we'll collect their tickets okay
got it all right Who are you?
You never introduced yourself.
Oh my god!
This is my actual Sonic OC.
Here.
Thank you.
Everything is in order.
He seems concerned about something.
You know how I wish?
What would be the best gift in the whole world if they like
re-released the Shadow game where he holds a gun?
I feel like...
Please... I don't understand!
Why we don't have, we have so many remakes, but not the one
where we saved the president.
The most important, we make it the most, the most important
game of all.
I want to fucking be shadowed a hedgehog and shoot somebody.
Like, I don't understand.
I don't understand why we can't have that.
Why we don't have that.
Is there anything we can help you with?
Hmm.
Do you sell gift bags here?
Um, no, sadly, but I have a plastic grocery bag in the back
I could get for you.
Hmm.
That's fair.
Oh, so cold.
Doki made a FPS V-tube.
You're shivering.
Do you need me to fetch your jacket?
Oh my gosh, what would your wife think?
Oh, no.
No, I'm good.
He's so cool.
He's so fucking cool.
Howdy.
God, please get your ticket.
I think that's a ticket.
But I really don't want to argue with this guy.
Everything looks good.
Thank you.
Seems the conductor doesn't want to argue either.
Can I get your ticket, youngin?
Right here, sir.
Thank you.
May I offer you any of the snacks we have on board?
No, thank you.
When I travel, I always pack my own sparkle gelatin.
It's a sparkly jelly that can melt any jaded heart.
No way I brought my own sparkle gelatin.
with me too.
It's my first day, and I was a little nervous.
Oh my god, we're gonna be best friends, Tails.
Honestly, always be, like, really good friends with, like,
the smart kid.
Because, like, they'll always have your... Because, like,
the reason why is that what if they become a millionaire?
It's like, they'll become the millionaire, and then you'll
always get, like, very expensive gifts later on.
Also, they're good friends, too, by the way.
It's not always a bum.
But it's not always about the money, you know, it's not
always about the money.
It'll be really good friends.
But also, the bonus, the bonus is that they're like, oh,
don't you want, hey, you want that iPhone?
Don't worry, man.
I just got my allowance.
Let me get that for you.
Don't be nervous.
You're doing great so far.
We're Sparkle Jelton.
buddies.
Unless they become a doctor.
Then they don't make any money.
Absolutely.
If you need anything, just let us know.
Thank goodness someone's on this train is normal.
Alright, let's see.
We'll talk to Sonic last.
May I have a ticket, please?
Thank you very much.
On top of it, if I see...
On top of it, if I A princess such as myself Must always be
punctual Princess?
Did she just say princess?
I actually don't know the lore with her.
I think like, I think Her and the chameleon, I don't really
Know much lore about them, but I think they're More like the
comics, right?
Like
Um Blink Aren't they like, aren't they like more so like
like sonic comic characters because i don't know much about
blaze or uh or um the iguana kid or gator you don't mind me
asking are you visiting from somewhere a separate dimension
actually a a separate what just here for amy's birthday then
i'll hop back to my own dimension They're not a comic
character.
Wait, which, which game are they from?
I quite prefer the birthday cake from this world more than
on my own.
I'm excited.
I'm a bit excited.
Oh, oh, oh, you don't say.
Well, I hope you enjoy your stay, princess.
Many games.
I like how the Sonic 06 and the Sonic Rush people are
fighting each other right now.
And I'm just like, who's she?
Should I bow?
Do I bow before the princess?
What are you doing?
Please get up.
Why can I not win with this group?
Alright, let's see.
Who's...
He?
She?
Can we please see your ticket?
Of course.
Excellent.
you and i hope you enjoy your stay with us absolutely i
appreciate it there's a calmness about oh he was super calm
sorry i was i have no idea who this person i just knew he
was a chameleon um there's a calmness about him something
about his presence puts me at ease do you consider me
calming he's looking right at me I study ninjitsu I believe
one can communicate through the subconscious fucking nerd
wow ninjitsu that sounds like a lot of difficult training
can you cling on to walls cling on to walls what kind of
question is that we
Weeb!
I most certainly can.
The conductor looks a bit too smug at that answer.
Alright, who else are you missing?
Okay, Amy.
Oh no, Gator.
Hello, my friend.
Can I get your ticket?
Yeah, of course.
As a gentleman of upsetting morals, I love to show you my...
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Maybe not Maybe put that down.
Don't need to show me your ticket, man.
He seems to be avoiding eye contact.
Is something a miss, sir?
I seem to have misplaced my ticket.
Could you speak up a little bit?
I couldn't quite hear.
I misplaced my ticket.
I don't know where it is.
It's not hiding his embarrassment very.
well get out don't you worry we'll take a look around for
you and see if it turns up that would be amazing thanks a
million seems as though we should keep our eyes peeled for
his ticket get out paying customers only can i please get
the birthday girl's ticket why certainly I don't know why I
said well the birthday discount certainly helped it must not
have been important why does who doesn't love a good bargain
and a murder mystery train just sounds so exciting it's
right out of my alley who doesn't love a good thrill you see
I'm a girl who loves a good true crime pot oh no she's one
of those people.
Maybe I should leave her to have fun.
Before we move along for you, before we move along for you,
Miss.
Oh, have fun!
Thank you!
Where do I use this?
That unlocks any door on the train.
Happy birthday!
The birthday girl gets the birthday key.
It's practically tradition!
Wait, the birthday girl gets the cheat?
That's not fair.
Why the fuck does she get to play on journalist mode?
And I actually have to try.
Very useful.
We'll use this wisely.
Thank you.
Alright.
Fuck.
Okay.
Rouge.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Well, hello, you too.
Sorry.
What can I do for you?
Good morning, ma'am.
Can we get your ticket?
My, my.
How forward.
Let me fetch it for you.
Wait, is it like in her?
Where did she get it?
Come back if you need anything else.
You hear?
Wow, she's so polite.
Very easy to talk to as well.
Ma'am, I saw you sneak that $20 bill out of my pocket.
Wait, what?
He has a wife!
And he already has a side...
He already has a trained wife, too.
I'm gonna have to kindly ask for that back.
Hmm.
Oh, this was yours?
Must have slipped out.
Here you go.
I may not actually be the best at judging characters.
Alright.
Sonic's last ticket, please.
thank you kindly happy oh wait sorry that's conductor i saw
that thank you kindly happy that someone is renown as
yourself aboard huh don't worry about it i just like helping
when igman took over i truly feared the worst but my kids
swore you would swoop in eventually and you did much other
than my sincere gratitude don't sweat a thing i'm glad you
and your family are safe wait a minute is he is he sonic the
hedgehog okay to be fair like how many other blue hedgehogs
out there how the fuck did i not know this was sonic like if
i didn't know it was sonic i should I wonder who this blue
hedgehog is.
Oh my god.
I can't believe that Sonic, that hedgehog.
I promise you an excellent stay on our train.
How many blue hedgehogs are fucking in this world anyway?
Sonic, have fun now.
Yes, have fun now.
Well, do.
Thanks.
Oh, wait.
There's one more.
That's not a character.
Mmm, yummy.
Don't mind if I do.
Dokimato FPS VTube.
Those are for our guests, you know.
Train.
Be sure Dokimato FPS VTube only gets one of those if they
ask.
Hmm.
Oh.
Okay, you're like, what about, like, there's metal Sonic.
Yes!
He's made of metal!
Like, he's fucking metal!
The Sonic's not made of metal!
Did the arms just kind of nod?
Actually, uh, Tring.
The conductor wants me to have the whole plate.
Hmm.
Good try, young buck.
The train and I have worked together for a long time.
You'll have to work harder than to get what you want.
Trat, those snacks look really tasty too.
But what about my OC, Jeremiah, the blue hedgehog, who looks
just like Sonic?
All right.
Did I talk to everybody?
Oh, wait.
What's this?
What's sticking out the napkin holder?
Oh, it's the Gators.
Ticket!
Say, wasn't someone looking for that ticket earlier?
Let's be sure to return this to its rightful owner.
Alright, let's make sure no one uses their ticket as a
napkin.
Alright, hello, I found your ticket.
Yeah, we might just have what you need.
Don't keep made our FPS V-Tube.
Why don't you show our friend here what we picked up?
Look, I found a menu.
I'll take one of each.
On second thought, maybe I'll wait a bit.
Jokey made a FPS VTube.
I was referring to the other thing we picked up.
Oh, right.
Sorry.
Oh, no.
Maybe they're hungry.
If they want to order food, they'll have to pay for it and
then we get more money, right?
Can I...
Oh, it's the same thing.
Okay.
I was going to say, would he call me stupid if I do it
again?
Ah, here it is.
That's my ticket.
Thanks so much to you both.
Was really worried you kicked me out, and I missed a murder
mystery.
Oh, old Tokimido FPS V-Tube.
Here would have their hands full kicking you out.
You're right.
I want to leave without a fight.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Whoa.
Wait, who made me both microwave expert and security guy?
Wait, am I the only staff here other than the train?
Where are the other people?
Wait a minute.
Where are the other Sonic OCs?
You're both all right in my book.
Thanks again for the assist.
This is like the most unrealistic thing.
They're only being one self-insert Sonic OC.
just let us know if you need anything else okay everyone
time for me to read out everyone's roles for the murder
mystery and that's my cue to leave I must prepare the
driver's compartment for departure ah the conductor's car
you remember our promise yeah you'll do everything in your
power to make sure our guests have a safe and enjoyable time
on the mirage express absolutely you can count on me the one
person you know in charge on the first day for a celebrity
and train.
Assist Dokimato FPS VTube and they need any help, won't you?
This is my self-insert Sonic OC fanfiction.
That's all I need to hear.
You have my trust.
Nothing more heartwarming than a conductor and his train.
Just me and my train wife.
excellent I'll be off I must take my leave everyone please
have a phenomenal time and don't worry about mucking up the
place otter this train is state-of-the-art and our systems
were dealing with all of that for everything else please
talk to Doki Mato FPS V tube here if you need anything else
sounds good absolute okay Wait, they sound the same now.
Oh, no.
I made Tails and Sonic sound the same and I didn't realize
because I could only do three voices.
Absolutely.
Will do.
Okay, bye now.
I like that guy.
Thank you all for following the outfit guide.
I sent you your look.
Oh, yeah.
By the way, do you guys know like Mirage from Apex Voices
Sonic the Hedgehog I said you all look amazing I trust you
all read your lore cards as well Lore cards That must be the
details of their motivations I suppose it makes sense Lore
cards aren't read out loud Otherwise people will know the
murderous intentions Yeah you guys didn't know that It's the
same voice actor
Yeah Now, on to the nitty-gritty for the murder mystery
game.
One of you will be murdered, and the rest are suspects.
Man, I wonder who's going to be murdered in the murder of
Sonic the Hedgehog.
Everyone has assigned roles for characters they will be
playing.
Participation is required, for it is my birthday.
Of course.
Birthday girl, mix the rules.
Sonic, you are a ship captain.
And you'll be stationed in the conductor car.
Naturally, that's where the captain would go.
Tails, you are the detective.
You'll be here in the dining car.
Indubitably.
Knuckles, you're...
Do I do remoralses?
Okay.
I assume you guys are remembering this for me.
Because I definitely do not remember already.
Tails.
Okay.
Sonic is in the conductor car.
Tails is in the dining car.
Knuckles.
You are the sheriff.
Around these parts.
We'll find you.
There's a saloon.
It's a train.
No wonder he's.
Okay.
Now I understand why he's a cowboy.
We'll find you in the saloon.
Got it.
Rouge, you are a business tycoon.
And Blaze, you're a titan of industry.
Both in the casino.
What's the difference?
There is none.
Hmm.
Sounds fun.
Vector, you're the butcher.
And SPO, The poet, both found in the light.
Wait, why the fuck is the butcher in the library?
Wouldn't a butcher be in the dining car?
This doesn't make sense, Amy.
You already fucked it up.
Both found in the library.
Like, all the other ones fit.
Why the fuck is the butcher in the library?
Unless it's forbidden love.
Oh my god, I'm cooking.
This is my self-insert fan fiction.
Very, very educated butcher.
Both found in the library.
Hear that, Espio?
We get to hang out together.
And do what?
Oh, yeah, what are we going to do?
Reign.
Maybe we can make...
A tower of books or something.
Books.
Shadow is the locksmith.
Hanging out in the lounge.
And last but not least, me, the journalist reporter.
I'll be moseying around with everyone.
Did you get all that?
Yeah, a tower made up of books.
Did I have the April Fools?
Oh my god, actual journalist mode.
Oh my god, she's actually a journalist.
Don't worry.
I'll do your Don't worry I'll do your Decima Will she Okay,
I don't want her to repeat that Um Um I was listening Hope
that's okay Stop
More than alright You can help ensure everyone's following
their rules.
Oh, that reminds me.
Oh, shit.
Thank God I have a map.
I have a map for each of you.
Everyone's station is marked on the map as well.
How convenient.
Map added to my inventory.
Oh, thank God.
I won't get lost.
Okay, guys, I don't need you guys to help me remember.
I have a map.
The rules or the games are as followed.
There is a murder amongst you all.
The murderer can kill a single participant, however they
choose, but you must physically be present with the victim
for it to count.
Everyone else must collect evidence throughout the train and
use it to integrate, interrogate fellow passengers to figure
out who's done it.
The murder will lie to get out of being accused, so inspect
everything you can.
Find clues.
And interrogate.
Oh my god, it's like Phoenix Wright.
And among us.
I'll set a time for you.
One hour.
So everyone can mingle and the murder can do their thing.
Is everyone ready?
Yeah!
Let's play!
Sounds like everyone's excited!
Yeah!
Stop, stop.
Everyone at your stations!
All right, let's find some clues.
Can someone die yet?
Ah, this is so exciting!
Our mystery is unfolding right under our very noses!
How thrilling!
I know, it's kind of scary!
Oh, man, I'm...
Oh, man!
I'm nervous too!
Shouldn't you two be out here mingling with everyone?
Yeah, detective, do your fucking job!
Who hired this kid to be a detective?
He's a child!
Well, actually, the detective and the journalist can't be
the murderer.
Wait, why can't they?
They can fucking kill if they want to.
Like, I think killing as a detective is like the perfect
alibi.
It can't arrest me if I'm the law.
So we're stuck here for an hour before going out and scoping
the place.
This way, there's always a neutral party.
Makes sense to me.
seems as though Amy's more excited about deciphering the
mystery anyway what do you think everyone's doing I don't
know murder except for the people in the library they're
doing something else oh probably inspecting their stations
and talking amongst one another everyone has a role to play
so they must be exploring their characters do you know what
their character motivations are Amy
no the lore cards are confidential no one knows but the
person who received wait but who made the lore cards i
thought you made it amy didn't you distribute them oh what's
this wait i thought we're not supposed to know your lore
tales oh my god minus one rp my backstory is that i was best
friends with a flicky that decided to join the evil doctor
igman kick-starting my desire for justice in the world.
My lore is that I'm a nosy person turned to a journalist.
She's so happy about that.
Not gonna lie.
That kind of sounds fun.
I wish I wasn't stuck on microwave duty.
Huh?
The...
The train started moving!
It's so fast!
Grab onto something!
What is going on?
Wait, a train isn't supposed to move?
It's a fucking train.
I'm slipping!
Hold on!
I can't!
What would be a shame if that chandelier fell?
Plus one RP for me.
I'm so immersed.
Guys, am I immersing you?
No!
Oh,
shit.
Don't worry.
Insurance covers all of this.
You're...
Wait.
What?
This isn't a dining car.
Who moved this here?
It's like...
Oh, my God.
It's just like...
It's as if I'm on the train right now.
You're both awake.
Yeah.
It seems the train has slowed down considerably.
Wow, how exhilarating.
I know!
The production on this train is outstanding!
It's definitely more intense than I expected.
I got a concussion and then we all got knocked out.
And now I have a concussion and we're here now.
So immersive.
It seems we've been knocked into the dining car's closet.
This train can't reach such incredible speeds.
We're getting our money's worth with this experience.
That's for sure.
Is this actually intended?
This is my first day, so I'm not really sure.
I don't recall them warning me about this ending interview.
You know I'm getting paid minimum wage for this too.
That's the worst part.
We should Check on the others.
Doki Meido, FPS VTube.
Could you get the door?
Of course.
Getting the door.
Hmm.
It seems that...
Oh, shit, really?
I wonder by what?
It seems the door is blocked.
I don't think it's budging.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck could be blocking the door?
It can't be this fucking bookcase in front of me.
No.
Amy Wait, am I actually, oh my god, I'm so fucking dumb Bro,
my Sonic OC is actually so stupid It was actually the
fucking shelf That's blocking the door that's in front of me
Okay, alright The Sonic OC reflects the streamer Um Amy,
give that falling shelf a whack or your pico-pico hammer.
Hmm.
Huh?
Let's find another way out.
I'll, uh, start looking for clues.
I'll search over here.
She did it.
She's not the red heron.
You thought she was on, you thought she can't be the
murderer, but she did it.
Suss.
It's always the first person.
I know, Amy.
She's hiding something.
I suppose she did wake up before us.
Something could have happened.
Listen, I know I'm the detective here, but all the best
detectives have sidekicks.
And I'm going to need your help.
Let's gather clues on why Amy is acting this way and
interrogate her about it.
Check out everything you can around this closet.
Then we'll show it to Amy to uncover the full situation.
Gather evidence and interrogate.
Got it.
We're going to pull a phoenix right on her.
What's this?
I'll need you to do everything in your power to make sure.
Make sure our paying guests are well taken care of.
Understood.
Alright.
I guess I gotta act.
You can count on me, Tails.
Don't worry.
I will make sure you'll have a great murder mystery party
while I get paid minimum wage on my first day.
I won't turn evil like your ex-flicky companion did.
Happy to hear it.
Now, let's get searching.
Mmm.
Awfully sweaty over there.
Pretty suspicious.
Something's always hidden in the trash.
Let's check there.
Sadly, it's empty.
But on the bright side, this is a very clean trash bin.
How do I become as optimistic as a kid because he's a child?
They haven't realized how fucked up the real world is.
Oh, to be a child again.
What do you think, Tails?
Want me to cook any of this for you?
When we get out of here?
Sure!
I normally never make microwave meals.
I prefer to cook.
My cast...
Oh my god, who let this child cook?
My cast iron skillet has gotten a lot of use lately.
I can cook a mean cast-iron pizza.
I've only had Michael.
I'm so poor.
I've only had Michael with lunches this week.
Alright, let's see.
Ah, the wet floor sign.
Keeping people alert and safe.
I'm on the college diet right now.
Once I slipped on some spilled juice at the ground, grocery
store?
No wet floor sign at all.
Luckily, Sonic was there to catch me.
My hero.
Wow.
Sonic really is as fast as they say.
But he was going so fast!
He also slipped on the juice!
We slid into an older gentleman's shopping cart!
Should have been me!
Well, it's the thought that counts, I suppose.
Super Posoda!
Thank you, the Super Chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Yo, I I didn't know you like Dango.
I actually love Dango Rampa.
I fucking love Dango Rampa, man.
I have so many actual, like, Dango Rampa.
Sorry.
Not immersing anyone in here.
Sorry, we're going to be out of immersive mood right now.
But, like, I actually fucking love that show.
And I love the game as well.
And I have, like, so many, like, Monocuma merch and stuff.
Because I love Monocuma.
Because the original voice actor for Monocuma was Doraemon.
and and I fucking love her work uh but yeah sorry back to
immersion the shelf blocking our exit it's currently not
budging hey dokey made a fbs v-tube look closely at this
wait is that from the oh wait that could be the hammer from
the something something hammer Pico-pico, hammer.
I wonder how this side of the shelf got smashed.
There's nothing this shelf could have fallen into.
I'm not sure this damage wasn't here before.
The train has too much upkeep.
I feel like this is important.
We should log it.
Check on the crack on the shelf is added to the inventory.
I'm pretty sure like Amy like fucking whacked this shelf or
something what what's this a rod wait is this wait that's
the hammer it broke the the tip is broken it looks like i
don't have originally been attached to something i'm not
sure if it's related to our mystery but i like spinning it
around so we'll keep it stick is added to your inventory
yeah this is the hammer it was amy's hammer i think we found
enough clues let's go Amy and find what really happened.
Alright, Amy, I got you.
What's the latest?
Oh my god, I never even talked to her before.
The game is afoot now, Amy.
Find any clues yet?
I found a spoon.
If we find two more, we can dig ourselves out.
Dig ourselves out on a train?
Amy, you stupid bitch.
huh okay that went like new grounds real quick uh i'll keep
looking all right start wait what do i want to talk to you
find any clues oh wait yeah that's me calling you stupid uh
start interrogation amy we believe you're hiding something
from us what you accuse me on my own birthday how dare you
This isn't going to be easy, is it?
It's my birthday!
I've been stuck in here just like the two of you!
What in the world do you think I'm hiding?
Amy was awake before Tails and I were.
What could she have done in that time?
Oh no, what could she have done in that time?
Okay.
Michael.
chili dog i told you i'm not eating until it's birthday cake
time let me think through this again amy was awake before
okay wait i wait i can just like say all the wrong answers
like there's no stakes involved okay attempted to okay
attempted to escape why would she like break the fucking the
bookshelves i don't think you're saying ali wadoki meadow
fps tube and i were knocked out you attempted to escape the
closet prove it show more evidence that i attempted to
escape or help me search for a way out do we have evidence
to prove that joki made oh fps b tube let me step you
through this first find the correct piece of evidence from
your inventory you mean the only two evidence that i have
once that has been deduced we must form our arguments to
fight back all right let's do it what proves amy attempted
to escape the dining car closet okay there's this the stick
which is her hammer let's get wait what i mean you need the
stick to hit the shelf oh i guess like the order goes with
shelf first and then and then like yo she'll be like but
what did i use to escape.
And it'll be like the hammer.
What?
Some damage on the shelf is supposed to approve something?
It fell over.
Damage makes sense.
You don't have no argument there.
You're just grasping.
Oh, okay, Tails.
What now?
Well, now we need to follow this train of thought.
How does the crack on the shelf relate to Amy?
I don't know.
What other possible evidence do I have?
Oh, wait, I had two.
So now I have to explain myself.
See, uh, well, uh, when I get stumped, I like to think.
What would...
Okay, Sonic would not be thinking.
What would Sonic do?
Sonic's a force to be reckoned with.
He's always running for it, collecting rings, crushing bad.
He never loses.
Like an endless runner game.
I play a lot of this on my phone.
Oh my god.
He's a TikTok kid.
He's an iPad kid.
Sure, whatever works.
Just close your eyes and...
Think.
What would Sonic do and find your argument?
Well, Sonic could just, like, I don't know, run through the
door.
Like, couldn't Sonic just break through the door with a
sheer speed force?
Alright, let's prove we're not grasping.
Let's follow the train of thought and fire a comeback like
Sonic would do.
Think.
Oh my god.
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
Wait.
what okay all right what would sonic do
yes i'm ready what do you mean what else do i need press yes
i mean yes okay all right here you go all right time to
collect those rings oh my god i zoomed in out of accident
i'm sorry
Immersion B Oh my god It's because I'm playing the video
game They gave me a video game So I zoomed in
Give me a second I'm locked in
I'm locked in, give you a sec.
Okay, all right, here we go.
All right, I'm back.
I'm back now.
I'm a little bit bigger, though.
Wait, yeah, I'm really...
Whoa.
Guys, keep being pretend it's all immersion.
Don't get unmerced, guys.
Don't get unmerced.
Okay, we're back.
We're back.
Share the cell phone.
You're telling me on a train this well-kept that the damage
was here before we arrived?
Well, I...
I believe someone is responsible.
for hitting that shelf.
He just said nothing was around for the shelf to fall onto.
What was the shell hit with then?
Alright.
Your fucking hammer.
The stick.
What is that?
A stick?
You truly believe a stick could do this kind of damage.
Think.
Oh no, come on.
Okay.
No way.
Now I know what invincible...
Why the fuck would you need invincibility mode on this?
Like...
Oh my god.
What?
Oh okay, now I know.
Guys, I now know why we need invincibility mode.
You're right.
A stick can do this kind of...
Can't do this kind of job...
Damage to the shelf on its own.
But if it's attached to something...
It could like...
Let's say...
This isn't a stick at all, is it?
It's actually the handle to your Pico Pico Hammer!
Sorry.
You attempted to hit the shelf out of the way, but you
failed.
The handle to your hammer snapped right off!
Oh!
Ah!
That's as Mubub said.
I tried to get his heart all out with my hammer.
But I failed.
I gave the shelf one big whack and then I figured it was no
big deal and I tried to hide it.
But I suppose my embarrassment got the better of me.
I just look genuinely sorry about the situation.
I never expected your hammer to snap like that, Amy.
What is that?
Wish.com?
It was one of my backups.
It's a little lighter to carry around.
I didn't think I needed it.
Well, lucky for you.
I'm a detective.
And I dabble as a mechanic.
The hammer's made of fucking wood tails.
Let me see both pieces of the hammer.
There's no way metal snaps like that.
There's no way.
That was a wood snap.
Just tighten things here.
A little elbow grease there.
And fixed.
Tails.
Thank you.
He's a carpenter's son.
He is.
They're all squeaky hammers.
How the fuck does plastic snap?
Like, that still doesn't mean a mechanic.
It's plastic.
Classic, classic wood mechanic.
According to my calculations, if you hit the shelf right
here, it could do the trick.
Alright, stand back!
BOOM!
The shelf completely shattered!
Incredible!
That was a fucking squeaky toy.
Who the fuck said it was a squeaky toy earlier?
She fucking destroyed the shelf!
No squeaky toy can do that!
We did it!
We're free!
Property damage.
Great job, Amy.
Let's get out of here.
It's super expensive.
It's squeak, but it's metal, but it squeaks.
Wait, is that?
Sonic!
Oh, my God!
Who could have done such a thing?
He can't be.
I can't believe Sonic the Hedgehog died.
in the murder of Sonic the Hedgehog who would have thought
it can't be Sonic he's got no someone murdered my darling
Sonic looks like the game's begun I'm finding a Who did this
once at once?
Why is she so happy?
Amy, wait.
I want to figure out who did this.
Wait for me.
Wait, what a whirlwind.
I'm exhausted already.
That was really convincing, Sonic.
Yeah, Sonic.
You can stop now.
Sonic?
Hey, Sonic.
You can get up the gun now.
Sonic?
And...
He's alive!
Body.
No.
Can't.
Move.
Oh my god.
What if it's Eggman?
What if it was Eggman all along?
Like the fucking, like, secret murderer?
Oh, what are you saying?
I don't understand.
I just need to rest.
Sonic?
Sonic!
Is he actually hurt?
Man, can't move.
Hey.
He's not moving.
Are those coins on him genuine?
My hands on his wrist I don't sense a pause.
My god, where did that voice come from?
Oh my god, there's no pause.
Sonic, talk to me.
Am I doing this right?
Why in the world is going on?
Is this part of the murder mystery?
Or is this serious?
Sonic!
Oh no, I feel myself panicking.
This is the most accurate depictions of panic attacks in an
animated game.
Calm down!
Donkey made a PSB tube!
What do I do?
Oh, I need you to do everything in your power to make sure
our paying guests are well taken care of.
Understood?
those guests are incredibly renowned which means they must
be remarkably rich you know my guy
so i leave their care to you doky madeo fpsb tube my
favorite employee my only employee surely you won't let me
down on this last ride.
It's my first day!
I need to catch up to Amy and Tails and get to the bottom of
this.
Even this is part of the game.
I just can't risk it.
I'll keep everyone safe, conductor.
You'll see.
I just need to feed Sonic the Rings!
I just got force- I'm sorry.
I just got force to feed him the Rings!
Yeah.
Alright, here we go.
Fudge top.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He's definitely not.
Oh my god.
We've... Guys, we've made it.
We finally got through the tutorial.
It only took one hour.
We fucking did it.
Tutorial done.
Whoa.
Look at this place.
Oh.
Tails seems like the most competent one.
Hey, Tails, where were you?
Where are you?
Joki Mado, FPS VTube.
I'm over here.
I think Amy's already gone on ahead.
It seems she's really excited.
I bet you if there was like the Walking Dead or like, oh, X
amount of people chose this route, A or B or stuff.
I will not be surprised in maturity of the people picked
Tails.
It seems she's really excited Did you need something from
me?
Yeah, just a question really How do I put this?
What if Sonic is actually hurt?
Just force feed him rings He'll never be hurt He's laughing
Sonic doesn't go down so easily He's on a train full of his
friends Like nothing would actually happen to him.
We're all just really committed to the mystery for Amy.
You have nothing to worry about.
Promise.
Plus, Sonic likes to nap in a lot of strange spots.
He's fine.
It's making a lot of sense.
But I can't shake what Sonic said to me.
Is this really part of the murder mystery game?
Or is there something deeper happening?
I need more evidence to figure out what's going on.
Can, okay, it's my job.
Okay, wait, yeah.
I'm gonna let him know it's my job, so he'll tip me.
It's my job to keep an eye on you.
The train rules say I gotta stay and watch after everyone.
You just won't hang out with me.
You just wanna hang out with me.
don't you?
I can see it in your eyes.
I mean, you picked me over Amy.
How is everyone great at reading people, but me?
As I said, the best detectives have sidekicks, so I'm happy
to have you.
If you ever catch me looking glum, though, just know it's
because, uh, where's my lawyer card?
Oh my god.
The last guy to work The last guy to work a case with me
ditched our practice to join the evil Dr. Igman.
Not a proper detective without baggage.
This is true.
Yeah, oh shit, okay.
Guys, I need you guys to know I can't do accents, like,
especially country.
Hmm, okay, wait.
varmits what what are y'all doing in my saloon i'm sorry i
can't see country access what are you doing all listen what
are y'all doing in my saloon he's trying so hard to stay in
character knuckles we're trying to figure out who murdered
sonic i can I can see that Amy mosey threw and told me all
about it Enough of that Oh thank God, okay, enough of that
Wonder how long he kept that voice up for Amy Well you're
wondering if you could tell us what you were up to before
the murder Anything to help us establish your alibi and nope
i have nothing to tell either of you leave me alone he's
sweating he's sweating
analysis he's obviously agitated about something but why
take it out on us it's him he's the murderer amy was the red
herring he's the actual murderer i know better than to argue
and Knuckles.
So it seems we're on our own.
Doki Meido, FPS VTube.
We need to figure out what Knuckles was up to while we were
all apart.
Let's investigate for clues and then interrogate.
Right!
Let's do it!
Okay, he's obviously he played video games and then smashed
it.
Clearly won't be able to give the game Super Monkey Ball a
try.
We think it broke when the train sped up.
The damages look more to be caused from punches.
Who could have...
Oh, I wonder who.
Could it be the Enkidna that has a name...
Whose name is based on his fucking hands?
No.
Whose entire fucking superpower is punching?
Nah, probably not.
What are you two looking at me for?
Smash arcade is added to your inventory.
No fucking way.
Alright, let's talk to the head.
The robotic arms here are really helpful.
what's the arm doing to my hair he fixed it up a bit that's
incredible what interesting tech uh oh should i fear for my
job a little bit how well can it microwave what's this
decent cash reward for finding this robot maybe i'll keep an
eye out Poor Omochow.
Hate to see them like this.
What do they do?
Medical mount?
What?
Interesting.
Wait, what the fuck did they do?
What the fuck?
Alright.
Oh.
Dokimido FPS VTube.
This is interesting.
What is?
It's just a few used cups.
But why are there three?
Oh god.
You know what they say about a kidness.
Um, Knuckles was really thirsty.
Doki made our FPS VTube.
This one has a lipstick on the rim.
That's not Knuckles' color at all!
Wait, where's lipstick?
Someone else.
Must have been here.
We should log this.
Oh, knuckles!
You slide, dog.
I think we have enough clues.
Knuckles!
What are you doing with Rouge the cat?
Oh, wait, no.
Wait, Rouge the bat.
What?
Like, bat cat.
Same thing.
One can...
Bats are basically flying cats.
I thought I told you, leave me alone.
I like your hat.
Oh!
Guys, I'm getting better at risen, people.
I told you, chat.
I told you I'm getting better at risen.
Knuckles.
Are you blushing?
I said, leave me alone.
It doesn't look like he's used to being complimented.
Uh, Josie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't believe Doki murdered Sonic for his passport.
Did you just adjust your hat a bit so we could see it
better?
I said, leave.
All right, can I take your order?
Hmm, not hungry.
Well, you're alright, just let me know, won't you?
Don't tell the robot, I want to keep my job.
Sure, like a butler of sorts, right?
Come on, Doki Mado, FPS V2.
You're not a butler.
Tell him that.
Yeah, like a butler, because I'm a little bitch.
Excellent, thank you, butler.
Dang it.
Oh, shit.
Wait, he doesn't want to talk to me.
All right.
Start the interrogation.
Obtraction.
Knuckles.
Doki made a FPS V-tube.
And I need to determine what you were doing during the hour
the murder took place.
I already told you.
Buzz off.
You're not getting anything out of me.
Thank you, Philly.
We don't need to say much.
What happened here is pretty obvious.
It is.
We have evidence too.
We do.
Jokey Mado, FPS VTube.
Just take a good look at our inventory.
I hope we're going to grab more evidence.
Because having two evidence tells the entire story.
And like, I literally just need a...
It's like a 50-50 on the order of the evidence.
What was distracting Knuckles during the time Sonic was
murdered?
His little date.
Yeah.
Wait, what?
Oh, wrong choice.
Doki made up FPS VTube.
Let's try again.
Wait, I lost the 50-50, guys.
Just like Doki Day.
I lost the 50-50.
Okay, the smashed arcade.
The arcade machine What makes you think I touched it think
oh no, okay.
Okay, it's guys.
I'm thinking
I'm thinking God I'm thinking so hard right now Oh my god,
you can see my brain Nice I did it As long as I don't send
any spikes.
Oh my god, where's the fucking light?
bub.
I did it!
I think!
This isn't a tough one, Knuckles.
Knuckles, you clearly touched the arcade machine because the
arcade...
Okay, your hair was viled at the scene.
Okay, wait, I want to see this.
You mean fur?
Fur, you mean spines?
Doesn't matter because it seems I'm wrong here.
Knuckles, you clearly touched the arcade machine because the
arcade cabinet is covered in punches.
Take that.
What evidence do you have that the damage is our punches?
Hmm.
What are y'all staring at my hands for?
My nipple hand.
Do you guys know that famous, like, Sonic the Hedgehog comic
regarding Knuckles' like, hands and then the the creator of
that Sonic comic became like an official artist for the
official Sonic comics did you guys know
do you guys know that a little fun fact for you um I don't
think the official Sonic channel would like vouch for me
though knuckles You clearly destroyed the arcade machine,
but why?
I needed a punching bag, and none were available to me.
Just a sudden urge to punch?
I vouch!
See?
What?
I told you, it was real.
He vouches.
It's real!
I believe repairing the arcade machine will give us our ass.
answer how would you i'm on it toky made on fps v tube
distract knuckles while i fix super monkey ball bring it on
oh don't worry let me pull up my fucking dream gear real
quick uh sorry it's knuckles my i can't pause the video game
uh this is this is more important than than an actual fight
here yeah nice dodged easy yeah oh my god so fucking easy
pink toky pink the arcade machine is fixed no don't look at
the score quick look at the scores i'm pulling it up now
okay what does that oh my gosh by one point oh my god noob
wait is that oh okay it says bread okay okay what does this
tell us nothing obviously it tells us something massive look
at the name at the top of the list it's vector it's supposed
to be in the library like he's like hey do you remember
where vector is do you remember if you don't remember don't
worry it's in bolded red letters it's supposed to be in the
library car.
You just got Vectored.
Oh yeah.
The picture is beginning to be painted here.
You compete with Vector to see who could get the highest
score.
And Vector beat you!
And in frustration, you destroy the arcade cabinet!
Ah!
He's punching the air in frustration.
You're guessing.
Where's your proof?
Where's your evidence?
Vector's a common name.
Prove to me he was here.
Now!
Okay, I'm thinking.
I don't know.
There's like, wait, but who's...
I guess it was like Rouge, Vector.
Oh my god, they're not playing the game.
Seriously!
It's Amy's birthday!
Why are they not taking care?
Oh shit, I'm sorry, I got distracted.
Why are they not taking her birthday?
Seriously?
Okay, I just barely made it.
Holy fuck.
Maybe I should put on journalist mode.
Now, Dorky made a FPS V-tube.
What proves Vector was here with knuckles?
Okay, I mean, my...
I have two evidence.
Like, what would my other evidence be?
It's process of elimination.
No!
I thought it was strange.
There was more than one cup sitting next to you.
Wow, you were supposed to be participating in the murder
mystery game for Amy's birthday.
You and Vector enjoyed some drinks playing arcade.
It's not like...
It's not.
I wasn't.
There was a woman there too.
Don't tell Amy.
I think we're on the right track here.
It's, as you say, Vector popped in at the top of the hour,
wanting to play the arcade machine with me.
We went back and forth, trying to figure the game out.
But when we did, we competed for the high score.
When he defeated me, I destroyed the machine.
No proof of his work.
win jesus christ man i was trying to fix the arcade cabinet
before you two came in honest i didn't want to be caught and
that's my story an alibi i've already told an abridged
version of this wait then why okay if he told this version
to amy why didn't he tell us like he already got caught
Knuckles, you're just fucking stupid.
You already got caught!
Why were you, like, trying to hide it?
Bro, this friend group has a lot of pride issues.
I mean, there's a lot of issues in Sonic the fandom.
That explains one of the used cups.
But what is a cup with a lipstick mark?
I don't want people to know that there was a woman here,
too.
wish was in here too never mind i'm okay with saying it
it's inconsequential not worth mentioning so you searched
around for something but failed made fun of our game and
left I'm nauseous that one But you offered a drink
apparently Listen I don't know why she showed up And I told
you everything that happened before the train sped up Are
you not satisfied?
Will you two relent?
Hmm I'm understanding the scenario Vector visited to play
games Rouge couldn't find something and left Dead Knuckles
destroyed the machine That all makes sense to me Thank you
for answering so many of our questions.
Actually, actually, that's not everything.
Is it knuckless?
Wait, there's more?
He's clearly innocent.
Huh?
Hmm?
He's sweating.
Wait, there is more.
I want to step back to something I noticed.
One more name on the highest score list.
Doesn't make sense.
Wait, what?
I just remember bread.
Talking Mado FPS VTube.
Can you take a look one more time?
An odd name on the high score list.
What is Tails talking about?
There's more?
Ultim?
What is Ultim?
Is it Ultim?
Because all of this is food.
And then there's Ultim.
Ultimate?
all the name yeah all the other names have food theme but
this one who here goes by ultim what the fuck is ultim you
may not know yokey made a FPS vtube but there is someone
here that goes by that title the ultimate life form oh oh
oh um truly the most edgy one out there
there's really someone here that i told you i look see i'm
i'm just trying to be immersive chat i'm just i'm just
trying to be immersive okay playing as my Sonic OC.
There's really someone here that goes by that.
Also, he's fucking...
Bro, you can't...
How are you in the ultimate life form when you suck at video
games?
Nothing sneaks by you, doesn't bud.
Vector and I were struggling so much with the game, but then
Shadow dropped by.
So, Shadow was here too?
We're not taking seriously of Amy's fucking birthday party!
What are you doing outside of...
your cards he taught us to gain and was the first to get his
name on the scoreboard vector and i then fought to be shadow
score they're both very annoying he only neatly had to
compete huh he gave me this before he left what did he give
a key where did shadow go to what was shadow's cart shadow
told me to lock the door I did not open it for anyone.
Then, he left.
When Vector was leaving, I locked the door behind him.
Saw no one else after locking the door.
That is pretty sus.
He did it.
Knuckles and Amy were the red heron.
It was shadow.
That's the honest truth.
So when Amy came through here, not too long ago, did you
open the door for her?
The shadow, I knew it!
I knew it was to the shadow!
No, I think she has some sort of key too.
That's right.
The conductor gave her that special birthday key.
Well, I have a lot of questions.
What happened in the library to cause Vector to come here?
Why is shadow locked in doors?
And what was Rouge searching for?
I don't know They didn't tell me Even though I asked with
that Cowboy accent Y'all You're gonna have to find them And
ask them yourself We did it We fucking did it We solved the
mystery That is not chat No sorry not not knuckles As of
right now I believe your story, Knuckles.
We'll only know for sure when we confirm things with Vector.
Fair enough.
The library is in the next car.
I'll open the lock for you.
Give whatever KO'd Sonic an earful for me, Detective Tails
and Butler.
I liked it better when he wasn't talking to us.
Well, do, Sheriff.
Come on, dokey made our FPS V-Tube.
Let's head to the library, Bunch.
But we got to knock first so they can, you know, at least
we're interrupting anything.
This is way more exciting than microwaving chili dogs.
Joki Mado FPS VTuber!
Coming!
Alright, let's go.
Knock, knock.
Ready to mosey down on the next car.
Oh, wait.
There's something in the trash can?
Okay, what's in the trash can?
Something's always hidden in the trash.
Let's check there.
Sadly, this one's empty as well.
Liars!
It's only a matter of time, Tails.
Have faith.
You're liars!
There was nothing in the trash can!
It's as they say.
One man's trash is another man's treasure.
Ha ha!
I think Tails is ignoring me.
Wait, trust.
Okay.
It's only... Alright, we're gonna keep pressing.
It's It's empty!
What do you mean?
It's still empty!
Wait, is there an extra trash can?
No!
This one's empty!
Trust the system?
Okay, how many times do I have to press the fucking trash
can?
Oh, they mean the next car.
Okay.
Alright, you got it, partner.
Here we go.
Onwards!
Whoa, the library.
Hang in there.
The library car.
This is a big ass fucking car.
This does not feel accurate to like the saloon back then.
This is wider than the saloon.
All this stuff's getting heavy.
I'll dump what I don't need.
Everyone's favorite journalist reporter!
Amy Rose is hot on the scoop.
I'm heading out.
You've been fabulously helpful.
Before you go, Espionage wanted to give you your presents.
My presents?
You're both too sweet.
Thank you.
Victor, it seems we have more guests.
company Amy there you are are you only found any leads yet
no she doesn't have to join us it's okay she doesn't have to
join us we don't want too many cooks in the kitchen oh the
detective pair needs help from the birthday this is exactly
why you're not joining us Amy this is
She knows everyone's allowed to be the sassy on their
birthday.
This tip is just too juicy to ignore.
I'll see you all around.
Don't worry, Sonic.
I'll be the one to avenge you and quick.
But how are you going to leave?
The door to the next car is locked.
You doubt the birthday, girl?
I have the journey.
Journalist mode key.
Right, right.
The birthday girl gets journalist mode.
Of course.
It's a birthday privilege.
I'll solve the case before anyone else.
Bye.
Amy may be hasty, but she's thorough.
Now, what are you two doing here?
Look, mighty suspicious, I say.
Wait, does that mean, like, the key that Knuckles has only
works for, like, one car?
So, like, oh, because it's not the master key.
It's, like, in the...
Wait, did how did Shadow get the fucking...
I fucking knew it was Shadow.
How the fuck did Shadow grab the saloon car key?
I'm the detective.
And so I can't be the murderer.
I knew it was Tails.
I knew it.
Uh, Vector, Knuckles, Shadow, and Amy were Red Herons.
It was Tails all along.
And I'm, uh...
Oh, he's a locksmith!
I forgot he's the locksmith.
Oh, yeah.
He had a job.
Sorry.
The ultimate life form actually has it.
Imagine being the ultimate life form and still having a job,
having to get a job.
Um, I'm here to ask if anybody's hungry.
Starm!
I'll kill you for a chicken Parmesan right about now.
Maybe kill isn't the right language to use right now.
Sonic's dead.
I'm Vector the Butcher.
I'm licensed to handle raw meat.
That's right.
And I'm Espio the Poet.
Ah.
A resident message from poet to reader meant to challenge
our delicate perspective with the most arithmetic of poise.
Fucking nerd!
Can I hear some?
Sure.
Oh my god, he's a poser.
Teardrops in the spring.
Can you hear me?
sing?
La la la la dee dee dee Oh my god, that was so beautiful
That was so beautiful, guys Oh my god Beautiful Was that it?
I have more of you like Cherry blossoms In the spring I'm
not Satisfied now, thanks I can't believe it, why did you
interrupt him?
It was going so well.
At least he's rhyming, I suppose.
I'll cry every time.
It was like a haiku, but like with more syllables.
It was almost like a haiku, guys.
It's just like, you know, it might be just like a little bit
more syllables than it should be.
But it was almost like a haiku.
Doki Maido, FPS VTube.
And I are here to establish both of your...
Alibis.
It's snowing on Mount Fuji.
Can you walk us through what happened after Amy had everyone
leave the dining car?
Oh sure it's simple.
We just explained to Amy actually.
All right.
Okay so after this we gotta talk to this and then we gotta
talk to Shadow and then we solve the mystery when we're all
sent off.
It's always that it has to be like the last person and I
knew it was Shadow.
else were red herrings.
Shadow and Sonic all pass through this library car.
Where Amy told me and Espio to stay.
I promptly picked up a book off the shelf and made myself
comfortable.
Vector got bored so he left to see what Knuckles was up to
in the saloon car.
Yep.
Where was Rouge?
We happened to see her...
We happened to see her lipstick stain on a cup after saloon
car.
Rouge came over to the library car seemingly to look for
something.
Maybe money?
I mean, she's always looking for money, right?
Then she went to search the saloon car.
She came back shortly after.
We heard her shout, no way!
At the brochure stand over there.
But she left back to the casino car before Shadow came
through and locked the door.
It has to be like some sort of money thing.
Like, that's the only thing that gets, like, Rouge going.
It's always, like, money-related.
After all, she's a thief.
Unlike me, who's also a thief.
Wonder what she found.
She's also been on the hunt for something.
After Rouge left, Shadow walked through the casino car.
Then entered the library car and locked the door behind him.
Importantly, why has Shadow been locked?
Yeah, why have you been locking doors?
What is he trying to hide?
Huh?
Shadow walked through the library car to the saloon car
where Knuckles and I were playing games.
He insisted on showing us at Super Monkey Ball.
I got so engrossed by the rolling monkey action, I hardly
noticed when Shadow left the saloon car.
I guess he walked through the library car to the casino car
again locking the door behind him.
Then return to the lounge car where he was meant to be
stationed.
When Vector came back, we realized Knuckles locked the door
to the saloon car.
We were stuck in the library car.
Yes, because you're supposed to be stationed at your cars.
Are you not taking this game seriously?
Shadow took the game seriously.
It's Amy's birthday.
That's when the train stopped sped up.
We're worried about the bookshelves falling on us.
But we got through it all right.
We sat trapped here until Amy arrived, asking questions.
She's the one that told us someone murdered Sonic.
And yeah, that's all that happened.
I mean, they don't look like they're hiding anything.
With all these locked doors, it seems Victor Espio couldn't
have left the library car.
Or the saloon car.
Thank you both for your cooperation.
We're just gonna peek around and we'll return with any
questions.
If you return with any...
Me.
I'll chop it up for you.
And if you like to be serenaded with a poem, I've got you
covered.
Thanks, guys.
Their albines seem solid enough, but we should still search
for clues.
Why are we looking for it is evidence that proves what
they're saying?
It's true.
We need to confirm Vector's reason for leaving his post and
determine if Espio was actually in the library car.
A tall task, but we can do it.
Let's get to the bottom, this tells.
Absolutely!
Yay!
Okay, well, what were the brochures?
I mean, there's books everywhere.
So obviously they've been reading, right?
Oh yeah, where's the trash can?
Something's always hidden in trash.
Let's check it there.
I hate to say it, but there's nothing here.
I really thought there'd be something there.
Don't keep me, no FPS V-Tube.
Are you sad there was nothing in the trash bin?
No.
I got one guide.
um i'm sure there's something hidden in the next trash bin
we're fine it's it's in the next one i swear i won't get one
guide again you really think so yeah we just gotta stay
optimistic yeah okay there's no way we get one guide again
right tails trust the stream joki made a fbsb team you're
pretty unconventional but i like that.
Is that supposed to be a compliment?
Alright.
Well, assume like what was she looking at the brochures?
Brochures!
There are travel destination ideas here.
Like amusement parks, caverns, hotels, restaurants.
Oh!
Joki Meadow FPS VTube!
Look at this!
There's a couple of maps here.
Wait, of what?
This is like literally... It's like...
It's a Sinclair line.
You go up or down This seems to be a map of The library car
The books are organized by genres Which are listed here I
love a good overhead map Let's take it Okay Should we take
this brochure about Cave 2?
Look, there's Stalagulatites Nah, leave it Yeah, that's fair
Wait, but what was the brochure that that Rouge was looking
at nobody shares my fondness for caves are they caves I mean
that makes sense actually well this is like scarily accurate
to my Sonic OC I wish we had time to pick them up I sadly
have no interest in picking up these books a lot of these
were knocked out by the train speeding up but Rouge pulled a
lot of these out searching for something.
What's she searching for?
What reckless behavior?
I feel sorry for the poor books.
The spines are creasing.
They're opening too far.
This kid feels empathy for everything.
Wait, what could it be that could like disprove what they're
saying?
Like, do I look at the books?
Wow.
I wish I could stop and look at all these books.
But Sonic needs me.
No time to rest.
Alright, let's move on then.
Hmm.
I mean, a little peek wouldn't hurt.
He's scavenging through all the books a little excitedly.
He's like a kid in a candy shop.
Or in this case, a genius in a train library.
That's odd.
I know some books have fallen out on the floor and
everything.
But...
Every book on these shelves...
It's an alphabetical order.
But this one...
Oh!
How the fuck did you notice that?
Who looks at the alphabetical...
Oh my god, what a fucking nerd.
This is...
This is why you're not hanging out with other kids, Tams.
This is why you're hanging out with adults.
It's the user guide to the Mirage...
Express.
The train we're currently on.
Do you think someone found it on the ground and put it back?
Hmm.
It is interesting.
Okay, that's mean.
Where are your children friends?
Where are your friends at your age, Taz?
Let's make a note of this.
Mirage Express manual is added to your all right we got the
oh wait what why is there another book what's this bright
red book oh yuck this reeks of the evil sign wait what dr
eggman what is this written by dr i mean he is a doctor is
he a real doctor i remember someone said that he's not a
real doctor and his name he just he's like impersonating yep
this is dr eggman's autobiography and recipe book he is he's
a real doctor he has a doctor he has a PhD what kind of
recipes who cares I wouldn't trust any book he's a he has a
PhD tails what do you have you're not dr. tails it's weird
this is even here do you even have a master's degree do you
have a license to be performing mechanical things did Do you
even want to trade school?
Maybe people just appreciate an omelette.
You may not be wrong.
Okay.
Oh, the seat?
No.
What would...
I don't feel like...
Is there anything else?
Okay.
Oh.
What other fucking...
Oh, wait.
Maybe the lights?
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Check out our boat.
club on the train book of the month gone gal that's nice
what what what can i oh wait do i have do i have all the
evidence okay let's see this is that and then huh
I don't have all the evidence yet.
The chairs are very comfy.
Puts me right in the Muto read.
Makes me want to take a nap personally.
In fact, maybe I'll rest my eyes a little bit.
Joki made a FPS VTube?
No.
Don't fall asleep.
Only got four hours of sleep, Tess.
There's been a fake murder.
I have a ring for every time a murder ruined my nap time.
That is a bit concerning.
Oh, poor thing.
That arm is really struggling cleaning up this car.
To be fair, I wouldn't want to clean up all this mess
either.
Let's just leave it alone and do a thing.
Yeah, probably for the best.
What?
I feel like I looked at all the evidence, except for hang in
there, I'm pretty sure that's not evidence.
A globe of our marvelous planet.
I haven't traveled around much.
The islands are fun and all.
But I love to visit some of the counties.
They're a lot of fun, honestly.
Plenty of the wonderful people and shops.
The food can't be beat either.
Sounds perfect for a vacation.
The conductor was talking about Spagonia.
Have you ever been there?
actually.
If you're ever visiting, be sure to stop at the university
and say hi to Professor Pickle.
I'll tell you everything about the area and make one
scrumptious sandwich.
I'll keep that in mind.
Thanks.
This group knows everyone and has been everywhere, haven't
it?
Yeah, they're fucking rich.
Doki Meido, FPSV Tube.
You're just a train boy.
You barely earn minimum wage.
Alright, let's see.
I feel like I talked to everything except for this.
I swear God, this cannot be a clue.
Let me talk to Vector.
Do you bring me any meat to chop?
I may be a butcher.
Uh.
But they confiscated my meat cleaver before getting on the
train.
You actually try to bring a knife on the train?
I mean, I did.
Stop, stop.
I'm a man of authenticity.
Tess, with a knife, I'm just a chef.
And a ketchup-stained apron.
Not a butcher.
You got a knife on you.
We definitely think you're the murderer.
Um.
Except for me.
But what if I hit the knife?
You know, I'm not the biggest fan of that.
a lot of thought.
Alright, can I start in my interrogation now?
I don't think we have enough evidence yet.
Why don't we take a look a little more look around.
Wait, then what the fuck?
What the fuck am I missing?
I looked at these books.
I looked at that book.
I looked at the table.
I looked at those books.
Is there more books that I forgot?
The door?
shadow supposedly walked through the library door before
going to the saloon car oh my god i was supposed to look at
the door my shadow left the library car he locked this door
on his way out there's got to be a reason he's doing this
should we make a note of it hmm i do believe we should
shadow's lock is added to your inventory i think we found
enough It was the fucking door.
Let's go interrogate Vector.
I have no idea.
I don't know.
I don't know what the reasoning is.
Guys, I don't even know.
I'm going to have to have the game to handhold me.
I don't know what we figured out.
Alright, start interrogation.
So, the two of us, you don't believe us, eh?
It's not that I don't trust either of you.
But...
proper detectives while examining the validity of your
alibis.
Doki made a FPS V-tube, and I are here to confirm two
things.
Why?
Vector left to go play games with Knuckles, and if Espio
really was reading in the library car.
Vector, we'll start with you.
Why did you leave the library car to visit Knuckles?
We're prepared to present evidence.
Hmm.
Oh, that's easy.
I got bored.
That's just a thing.
Why would you put the butcher in the library?
It doesn't make sense, Amy.
Amy.
This is not immersive.
Why is he in the library?
Unless he's getting some meat.
What?
I wasn't entertaining.
Oh, damn.
SPO.
Damn.
That sucks, man.
I was entertaining him enough, it seems.
Vector enjoys being so...
social.
Damn, Espio.
Just no chemistry, huh?
Just no chemistry.
Plus, we were instructed to mingle.
I remembered the arcade machine in the saloon car.
So I figured I'd go check it out.
This seems to line up with the information we gathered with
Knuckles.
That brings our intention to you, Espio.
Will you enter the library car found something and then left
you said you immediately started reading but you're you
actually reading the entire time you were in the library car
hmm of course he was huh once espio starts reading he
doesn't stop till it's done i've seen it happen damn simp it
must have been a good read.
What was the book?
SPO doesn't owe you that, detective.
Where's the warrant?
Huh?
I won't talk until my lawyer's here.
Let the man live.
What if it was embarrassing?
What kind of things do you think I read?
If you won't talk, I have a hunch on what that book might
be.
Hmm.
Yoki made a FPS V-Tube.
Can you help me out?
Let's see.
I wonder if I have an evidence that's just a book.
Guys, what book do you think SBO may have been reading?
Hmm.
I must have.
I wonder, I wonder which one is a book.
Hmm.
a manual you think espia was reading instructions what
argument could you possibly have to support this think oh no
it's time it's time to it's time to parkour oh no there you
go i like how it's like sonic as like the oh no no why did i
jump why did i jump wait what there's no i got confused i
was That was a new mechanic that was introduced And I
wasn't, I wasn't sure what was going on Okay, alright, I
figured it out I got confused They gave me a new mechanic
And I wasn't prepared I didn't have time to actually
register What it was, but it's okay, I'm a gamer I like how
I like My name's up there too There are books scattered
Around the floor, sure But raining books on the shelves were
all In alphabetical order all except this manual needs
someone at the very least picked up the manual up and put it
back in the incorrect place bum bum
this lack of attention to detail isn't normally like USPO
hey now I won't have you insulting my pal like this calm
down vector i know you me well but i can handle myself
apologies espio a butcher and a poet friendship can form
anywhere that is indeed the book i was reading the mirage
express manual trains are okay trains are cool i like trains
In that case, we'd like to ask you a few questions about the
manual.
Doki made our FPS V-Tube, if you don't mind.
That's me.
Can you ask SBR some questions about the manual?
Just flip to a page and ask away.
Oh, I see.
Quiz SBR about the manual to prove he read it.
Which page should I quiz him on?
I don't fucking know.
362.
What efficient and extraordinary extremely accurate
technology was installed to assist and keep what is he like
does he like fucking has like that type what's that memory
photographing memory like what the fuck keeping those trains
spotless oh my god okay this is like a random story but this
reminded me of the time where like um i and i think it was
like in middle school i was like chosen to do like some
fucking like uh some like uh academic tournament or
something where it was like separated by different uh
different subjects like psychology math reading english and
stuff like that and then like and like special subject and
then i was selected to be on that team it was like this like
academic quiz so like you have to have like like like
multiple choice questions to answer debate and uh Do not say
nerd Do not say nerd writing an essay And you're competing
against like Different types Different schools And then like
I was studying for it And then um You know I was studying
for it And like the bus ride To like The venue Like because
like I was like You know Getting some last minute study on
And this kid Like sat in Okay I was also a kid But this kid
like sat next to me And then he was like oh you're doing
you're like um brushing up and i was like yeah i am and then
he was like give me a page and i was like what
it was like give me a page and i was like oh and i was like
this page and then he read word to word what it was on that
page and then that was the day i realized i'm not special
I was not special.
I'm not nerd enough.
There is always someone stronger.
Okay.
What efficient and extremely accurate technology was
installed to assist in keeping the train spotless?
it is um robot okay and then like i tested him in various
other pages and yeah news to say i'm pretty sure that kid
did really well
robotic arms during events they can perform a variety of
tasks and are responsible for cleaning up the trash and
messes afterwards he was the bigger nerd I remember the
conductor saying that the train can clean himself.
So, I have a feeling the train company just didn't want to
hire any janitors.
I mean, like, why would you need to hire janitors when
literally the train does it for you?
Like, it doesn't even get paid.
Robots don't need to get paid because they don't have
rights.
The robotic arms can also detect weapons or explosive beings
brought onto the train, ensuring passenger safety.
your ace that question joking made of fps v2 hit him with
another one oh my god we know we know already we don't need
to hit him with another one oh my god tails he definitely
knows what he's talking about i'm giving a literally a
random page what is a mirage express cancellation policy no
refunds and you will be charged a no show fee this does not
apply if you're over the age 65.
Gee, the person who made this rule must have been over 65.
He was like 66.
Last one.
Joke, he made an FPS V2.
Let's see if Espio can go 3 for 3.
After the first one, it should be okay, Tess.
Oh my god.
Don't be jealous that he's a bigger fucking nerd than you
are.
Like...
Alright, 402.
What was implemented to support the conductor duties and
means general train obligation an intelligent data
processing system it works in tandem with the conductor to
ensure smooth travel for guests i remember this the train
has an autopilot but it can't access its full suite of
capabilities without the conductor present no did i pass
your little test no no i don't want to to keep going yes
totally it's wild you're able to retain all this information
so quickly a poet's brain is often surprising i don't know
if i'd be bragging about that clearly read the manual those
answers feel far too specific to be oh my god tails just
accept it is a bigger nerd than you Oh my god, Tess.
And you both had the nerve to question my buddy like that.
Don't we want to be supportive folks who read?
You don't even read, Vector.
You have to admit, though, reading the entire time a murder
occurred does sound a bit suspicious, even if it's true.
We answered all my questions so calmly.
That's very impressive.
No, no.
cautious attitudes.
Vector was the only one to see me reading after all.
My alibi is hard to substantiate despite being the truth.
Well, I definitely read through the manual.
So I suppose we can...
Espio, is that true?
Vector was the only one to see you reading?
Yes.
That's correct.
Wait, what about Rouge?
Wouldn't Rouge see me read?
Frankly, I don't believe that can be true.
And we have Evans to back it up.
Joki made our FPS V2.
Wait, we do?
He always puts me on this spot.
We do?
Who also saw SPO reading?
Uh...
Um...
I guess... The map?
Uh...
Um, oh, Shadow, wait, what about the menu?
Not sure what we're trying to say that.
Don't waste my time.
But what if people are hungry?
Okay, Shadow's love.
Shadow's blog?
Please, pray, tell me, what does that have to do with
anything?
We're up, Doki Mado, FPS, VTube.
Let's get our argument together!
Okay, are you also playing this little game while we're
thinking, too, Tess?
Do we both have any Dream Gear?
It's okay.
I figured it out.
I'm thinking right now.
Guys, this is what happens in my brain.
You guys are like, what is going on in that little tomato
brain of hers?
This is what happens.
I'm playing a little Sonic game.
Wee!
Oh my gosh, I'm doing so well.
Yay!
Oh my god, this is like longer than before.
Alright, nice.
I got 23 more.
Just like me.
This is how my brain works on Sonic.
Shadow walked through that library car to get to go to the
saloon car, where he set the original high score on the
arcade machine.
Yeah, but I ended up beating it.
It wasn't a high score for long.
Crocs are natural gamers.
Espio said he saw Shadow enter the library car.
But, he's mentioned nothing about Shadow's return.
He only mentioned that Vector came back.
When Shadow left Knuckles and Vector in the saloon car,
Espio was fully seated reading his book for a good while at
that point.
We know Shadow had to walk back through the library car when
he left the saloon car.
So, there's absolutely no way Shadow and Espio...
Didn't notice one another on Shadow's return trip.
Oh, he's cooking.
I mean, it was a simple slip-up.
I was just fully immersed in my book that didn't notice
Shadow.
Yep, yep, that's it.
When nerds attack each other.
Nerdfight, you're telling me that sound of the door opening
and locking wouldn't have cost.
you to look up.
Nerdfight!
Well, you see?
Take that!
I can sense desperation here.
Defending the argument that he was reading the entire time
isn't easy.
So if you didn't see Shadow returning from the saloon car,
it locked all the doors.
And at that moment, were you really in the library car at
all?
How would SBO leave?
Shadow locked all the cars.
No one saw SBO in the car.
saloon car she we went to the casino it's a mystery my dear
doki made of fbsv sorry it's a mystery my dear doki made of
fbsv tube um one that would love for espio to solve oh my
god he was gambling the biggest crime are you even over 21
the gamble espio you gotta believe me That cool demeanor is
vanishing.
I so involved my book, I didn't until a shadow passed
through the library car.
Honest.
When Vector returned, he even had to tap me on the shoulder
to get my attention.
Yeah, I think I remember.
I think.
I think I remember doing that.
I must avenge my friend's death so I can ask you again, SBO.
If you weren't there for Shadow to see you reading, then...
How did you leave the library car?
I wasn't.
I didn't.
How does this seem right to me?
Tails definitely feels like he's on to something.
But I don't see it.
Was Espiel simply sitting, reading?
Or did he send me a badge to not notice?
Shall I return to the library car?
What should I do?
Join Tails.
hmm you know what you know what I'm only all in on Tails
joining Tails no I can't interrupt Tails while he's on to
something I'll let him continue this line and questioning
and Docu made a FPS VTube my fate wait does he like get more
and more like are these like real memories or he just like
made up these memories at this point fate because like i met
him like one time my favorite and beloved employee please
like it doesn't even feel like his actual flat like made up
flashback protect the passengers aboard this train they must
be taken care of if you fail oh yeah that's that the
lawsuits will be torturous.
Don't allow such an old, feeble soul to get sued.
I was going to be like, I just met that guy.
How do I have so many flashbacks?
I have to make sure our guests are taken care of.
Oh my gosh.
I'm hearing voices.
I have to speak up.
Tails!
We have a piece of evidence that can answer all of our
problems.
Alright, my fellow associate.
Lay it on me.
What piece of evidence shows Shadow and Espio Couldn't have
seen one another.
The map!
Look at the map!
This one, because it's my last evidence.
Now let's get my thoughts in order.
Alright, it's time to game.
Sorry, give me a sec.
I'm gaming real quick, Tails.
Don't worry.
When I'm finished gaming, I'll be able to answer your
question.
Just gotta finish gaming now.
Wee!
Oh my gosh, ooh.
It's gonna be risky.
Okay, I got that.
Okay, I'm in.
I'm fucking in.
I don't have to worry now.
Wee!
I already got 70.
Oh, that was scary.
I wasn't paying attention there.
It's okay.
We're set.
Yay!
I'm gaming.
Gotta work on those brain cells.
The library map!
I see!
See the exits?
They're right across from one another.
A straight path.
The shadow walked down the straight path.
There's a way.
SPO and shadow couldn't have seen one.
Wait, what?
Oh, I guess if he sat there.
Over here.
And then he goes this way.
Yeah, you just need to sit on that one chair.
Or here.
No, no, here.
Looks like you have to point out exactly where on the map.
Map, map, map.
You mean...
Where could Espef been foreshadowed to not see him?
Oh, here.
Here.
Interesting.
That's where I was sitting.
Oh, I thought it was like Espeo that not see him.
Okay, I thought he meant Espeo.
Okay.
And then I read, oh, where could he sit foreshadowed to not
see him?
Interesting.
That's where I was sitting reading my book.
Yeah, of course, that's exactly where.
this.
When I returned from the saloon car, Espio was in the same
spot.
I made him like, I made Vector like dumber and dumber the
more I voiced him.
That confirms it then.
You see, Shadow and Espio couldn't have seen anyone there
from the spot.
Because Hippocus is in the way.
I can't believe I'd suck my neck out of it for you, Tiz.
I can't believe it.
You fucking made an innocent chameleon cry.
I suck my neck for you, man.
I defended you.
There's No way Shadow could have seen Espio or vice versa.
It makes a lot of sense why.
You never mentioned Shadow's return, Espio.
There's just no way you had seen him.
Camp, I defended you!
I can't believe it isn't a proven guilty.
I apologize for losing my call back there.
I felt like I was grasping despite telling the truth.
I'm glad you all believe me now.
Your alibi isn't the most airtight, but I have no further
points.
I'm sorry I gave you a trauma a little bit.
Thank you both for answering all our questions.
We did it.
Another pair of alibis validated.
Yeah!
Who the fuck did it?
Too many locked doors to worry about.
I'm glad everything's straight.
Okay, I bet you.
Nobody did anything and Sonic just got overdosed with like
chili dogs.
you i swear okay um quote me on this right now nobody did
anything and sonic just ate too many chili dogs and passed
out i'm exhausted i'm gonna crash here for a bit those
chairs are so comfy likewise i could use a breather sadly
our work isn't done i have plenty of questions for Rouge and
especially Shad.
What about Blaze?
No one ever said anything about Blaze.
Like I I like how no one said like she's so irrelevant that
no one has said anything about Blaze or like Blaze has done
anything at all.
Amy must have kept it open when she passed through earlier
then that's our cue to leave.
See you later vector and SPO.
Give them heck and if you need any meat I'll keep my poetry
sharp for you both A murder is on the loose While doors keep
getting locked Tick, tick, tick, tock Goes the clock While
our heroes are in The caboose I'm blue, badaddy, badaboo At
this point I'm feeling pretty confident In our detective
abilities We're really doing this Come on, Doki.
Doki Meadow, FPS V-Tube.
Let's see what's next.
Coming!
Alright, let's see.
Yeah, I'm ready to go.
The mystery cause.
Alright, is Amy gonna be in a casino?
Wait!
Oh my god, he has a mustache!
I thought they were all children!
What the fuck?
Oh, this stuff is getting heavy.
Don't need.
Rouge, there you are.
We have a lot of things to say to you.
We visited every train car so far and everyone said they've
seen you wandering about.
It's high time you told us why.
My, my.
Talk about a warm welcome.
Quit to that point.
Aren't you, darling?
I see you brought the microwave master with you.
Oh, master?
Oh, please don't let that be my legacy, bro.
What the fuck?
People will kill for that.
Tales is right.
Folks have brought you up a lot.
Care to explain?
Hmm.
Tell him, Rouge.
We're gonna need that help.
Oh my gosh.
She actually has a role.
She has...
Oh my god, guys, Blaze actually talks and has a role in this
game.
Alright, I've been hunting for a treasure, rumored to be
stored here on the train.
I knew it, I knew it was treasure.
It's always something.
It's always about money.
I shouldn't tell me about treasure in the interview.
Since I'm a part business tycoon...
Part purveyor of fine collectibles.
I knew how to find it.
Tell him what it is, Rouge.
All right.
Well, it's a...
Oh my god, a Faberge cake.
I don't understand those.
Like, people have actually spent, like, millions on Faberge
eggs.
But, like, I don't understand.
It's just, like, it's just, like, a bedazzled egg.
It's just a fucking bedazzled egg.
Like, I don't understand.
Why are they so popular?
Where are those?
What I said, eggs with, like, fucking jewelry on it.
It's a really fucking fancy egg.
Wow, that sounds extravagant.
Please, don't tell me you accepted Amy's birthday invite
only to find that egg.
Don't you care about Amy?
The girl that clearly has a lot of friends?
Sorry, Amy.
A woman can have multiple goals I gave Amy her birthday
present already So everything's well taken care of Wait, is
Blaze French?
She wrote me in on the hunting media Okay, I can't do a
French accent either Wee-wee She wrote me Wee-wee,
mademoiselle She wrote me in on the hunting media I stayed
here while she searched the train cars for clues
I deduced that the Faberge Chaos eggs is here in this train
car locked in a safe wait so the treasure is real it's
actually here and what did you manage to find Rouge well why
don't you both take a look oh it's like the blueprints i
found the blueprints in the library car with a safe code
written right on it a score of a lifetime like the train's
blueprints please ruse let's see that uh-uh-uh finders
keepers a sweetheart there's a problem
distance you want a child's help what kind of problem the
elevator behind a security guard lead us right to the room
holding the fabric sheet chow a oh it says chow i thought i
thought that's i thought that says chaos egg i was like damn
i didn't realize they made chaos eggs holy shit oh my god
they they bedazzled a fucking chow egg but we're not getting
anywhere darling without the guards bro it's a child kick
the chow don't just throw just pick it up and chuck it what
is he gonna do fight back bro fucking throw him in the ocean
we need to plan to get that car to use the elevator and our
Chance of success grows with everyone's help.
So who wants to help you steal the Faber-Jay Chow egg?
Blaze, you don't have a problem with this?
I see no issue here.
Sounds like a fine business venture.
Her lower card must be influencing her decisions here.
Either that, breaking the rules must be refreshing for a
princess.
Joki Mado FPS V2.
Do you have an opinion on this?
Do not kick the chow.
Kick the chow!
They become rare if you kick the chow.
They turn into evil chows.
They're rare.
Stealing is for squares.
Damn, I'm so cool.
Well, you say that stealing is for squares.
I think the only square here is you microwave master I must
admit that wasn't the coolest thing I'm so cool so cool I
heard someone say no my cool and mysterious reputation it's
crumbling all right all right I'm in I'll help I'm hope I'll
be a square the women say I wasn't cool, so I got
peer-pressured.
I suppose if both Blaze and Doki Meadow FBS V2 are in.
Okay, let's get that Faber J chowting.
That's the ticket.
Happy to have you both on the team.
Chew.
Now, we must plan.
Oh my god, we're doing a heist.
It's heist time.
Oh boy.
What have we gotten ourselves into?
Chow Egg room is behind a locked elevator door.
The security guard has the access key.
Do we kick the guard?
Attack him!
I can't say I'm comfortable attacking Chow.
Let's keep bodies to the minimum, shall we?
Less fun, but I agree.
Why would you agree with that, Rouge?
You have a gun!
Access to Fabric.
Okay, I guess we don't...
I don't attack the guard.
Do we distract...
the guard distract a guard what do we distract them by i
guess we can like bribe anyone have anything we use for a
bribe i have a pair of tweezers oh here's a training card
i'm not giving you anything but you're a princess you have
stuff you can just go back to your other dimension ask like
dad to buy you more things me bribing isn't a way to go we
have oh my god but there the easiest choices bribing and
attacking distracting them perfect we're all charming enough
for that to work that was actually a really nice thing to
say doki made our fps vtube is everything okay i've never
seen you smile at that oh my god i'm in guys i'm in
until sally the squirrel comes over then then i'm sorry ruse
your gonna get see I know my fucking sonic lore I'm just
like you guys seems they don't know how to take a compliment
you guys Sally doesn't wait is she a squirrel I don't
remember wait wait maybe I'm not
she is.
I'm fully committing.
She doesn't wear
oh Chick-buck squirrel.
I was half in.
I was half right.
Wait, she's isn't cat in?
Is it because she doesn't wear pants?
But they don't fucking tails doesn't wear pants.
Alright.
Uh-huh.
If I'm going to be in a casino, my poker face needs work.
Who's distracting the suit?
Rouge wore pants?
Look, that's pants.
Who's distracting?
Well, obviously Rouge, right?
Rouge.
Of course I'll distract them.
Who could resist my benjamin charms?
I'm not sure how effective your charms would be on a chow.
Plus, your flight might prove useful.
bring the distraction makes sense.
Fair enough.
Let's think it over again.
Wait, who else is going to be distracting?
Tails?
I mean, he's useless in everything else, right?
Sure, I could be the distraction.
I don't like the way you set that.
Okay, then, Blaze!
Oh my god!
No, I really could do it!
Sorry, buddy.
I think you'll be better off.
Okay, Blaze!
Blaze!
I don't know.
They're all, like, distracting enough.
I think you can distract a guard, please.
In my life, I've never let a single person down.
I won't falter.
Great.
Her voice.
Oh, wait.
She was stoic this entire time.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Sorry, I gave her too much personality.
Her voice was so stoic.
I have chills.
guess yeah she looks like raven so i you're right she she
looks like raven so i should have fucking i should have like
known um well i trust her moving on what's the distraction
um uh about their partner and kids push a bunch of poker
chips to the floor content okay yeah i'll be like oh mr chow
i'm so dumb the claw machine is stuck
who puts that wait there's no claw machine in the casino
this worked great as a distraction let's continue the plan
Sumimasan, Mr. Chow.
When the card distracted, Rouge, how would you get the Axis
card?
Okay, pick their pocket.
I'll snatch the Axis key, no problem.
The Chow in uniform won't notice a thing.
Excellent, we can count on you, Rouge.
from them if you can help it no promises the card obtained
we need to get blaze out of there dokey made a fpsv tube
what's your plan um push the security card over here i'm
still not comfortable it's just a little push that child's
low to the ground it won't hurt them but what if they start
crying it bring unwanted attention to us was that accurate
was accurate to the blaze why is someone who cries so easily
a security guard anyway exactly decent point let's think of
something else fucking cowards you guys are cowards all
right say there's a drink without a coaster I can't think of
nothing worse Despicable I would never allow such a thing in
my kingdom The guard will go running immediately I'm sure of
it Great And with the guard distracted We'll all head to the
elevator And just like that We all make it to the elevator
side we i don't know sing victory alcapilla now that's a
proper victory oh no one last security measure we didn't
account for it wait what we missed the spouse route i'm
making sure they're like they're like rejected they reject
every i i chose like the worst idea because they actually
rejected every bad idea every amazing idea i had what do we
do about the mechanical arms attacking High five The end of
those arms are closed I'm not touching him My high fives
aren't giving away Willy Nilly They are to be cherished I
don't think my hines would survive A high five for them
unless we think this See?
It's such a great idea They never like my good ideas Why ask
for my opinion I'm like I should be able to disengage them.
I'll just need some time.
That leads us nicely to our next question.
Oh, no.
Tails is taking a while and the arms are tightening their
grip.
Oh, my God.
Am I getting choked?
Why am I the one getting choked?
What the fuck?
Everyone else is okay.
Um Um Cry Tails managed to do it Darling's I'm happy to say
This plan is perfect If everyone is ready It's time to
execute I'm ready Let's begin Alright let's see what's up
That elevator All right, let's do it.
Did I do it?
I did it.
Yeah.
Yay.
I did it.
I knew the plan would go without a hitch.
So fucking easy.
We couldn't have made it this far without you both.
You have my gratitude.
All right, planning beforehand was very thorough.
I must admit And it was executed to perfection Enough
chatter Now we claim our real prize I have the safe code
right here On these blueprints Let's claim our Fabricier
Chow egg Alright So this one No question Let's got to be a
safe with our treasure Entering the code on the blueprints
Entering the code on the blueprints And find out Rouge And
it's sweetheart.
Let's see.
23, 04, 01.
Yeah!
What if it hatches?
It's here.
I have it.
It's so ugly.
All right, before anyone else is seen, let's get it out of
here.
Hold on, kiddo.
It can't be so hasty.
You truly think that's all there is to this egg?
The egg is real.
I don't know if there are secrets whatsoever.
Rouge, spit it out.
What are you hiding?
Only three of these eggs were ever made.
Each hiding their own individual secret.
I like secrets.
No one knows the secret because anyone who's opened one of
these has never lived to tell their tale.
Doki made our FPS VTube open it.
You can open the egg?
Yes, it's a fucking egg.
Do you not see the gold thing right here?
Oh my god, Tails.
You're like a genius, but yet you're so fucking stupid
sometimes.
Yeah, sure it can.
And all of you will bear witness to its secret.
Bougie, I don't know if you should.
All you need to do is twist it.
You won't.
Tick, tick, tick, tick.
Oh, maybe that's why no one fucking...
No one fucking lived because they died.
Is this a bomb?
Huh?
Why do we have a bomb on a fucking train?
Wait, I thought like the robot arms made sure we don't have
bombs in this train.
Uh-oh.
There's just no one lived to tell the egg's secret because
each egg is a bomb.
Huh?
I think you're onto something, kid.
It sure sounds like a bomb.
We need to dispose of that egg now.
Wait, we throw in a save.
It'll be fine.
It's like bomb proof.
Dispose of it after a hard work?
Rouge.
Fine, fine.
But what do we do?
Where do I put this thing?
Guys, enough talking.
Just fucking throw that bomb!
Why are we still talking?
That's an excellent question.
What do we do with it?
Whoa!
Oh my god, there's a lot of...
Tell the egg to stop.
Yeah.
Stop.
That did nothing.
I can't believe I just did that.
Okay, take one for the team.
Let's do it.
I'm going to do it.
Give it to me.
I'm going to be a hero.
Get away from his far spot.
Just remember me as I am a hero.
Don't keep me though.
At PSV too.
We won't let you do it.
I mean, that's what they want.
Who are we to stop the microwave?
Kids obviously not going to sacrifice themselves.
Their body's far too scrawny to contain.
Oh, just because I'm a tomato.
Doesn't mean I won't be able to shield us from the fucking
blast True Let's think of something else quickly.
Okay, clearly clearly it doesn't work.
Okay, have blaze set to stomp on the egg
Okay, okay throw it lock it in the safe quick put the egg
back Rouge It's fine.
It's going back in Huh Hells, the safe won't lock.
The door's staying open.
Close the door and twist the dial.
I obviously am.
There must be some weird way to relock the door.
Please, there's no other buttons or dials.
How are you supposed to?
Don't have time to mess with this.
Think of something else.
Oh my god, it wasn't that.
That seemed like the...
Oh, it's just a mistake.
Let's fuck it.
If we die, we die.
Are you insane?
Do you want to sub...
If we die, we die.
We need to dispose at the mom Doki Mado FPS VTube That is
our goal Listen, I get that But, hear me out What if the egg
Isn't a bomb Wait, that's right Doki Mado FPS VTube I think
you're on to something Oh my god, I was cooking What's right
spit it out kiddo we don't have any time okay we clear that
a lot of time there was a lot of options like we had so much
fucking time sorry it's just espio did say something
interesting when we quizzed him about the train's manual
wait we did what do you say um what's efficient extremely
accurate technology and saw saw to assist in keeping the
train spotless robotic wait are you of choice, whatever page
I asked for.
They can perform a variety of tasks.
Yeah, I said that!
I remember.
I was like, when the robotic arms know about the fucking
bomb, it can't be a bomb.
I knew it.
I called it.
I was so smart.
I told you I remember things.
Those robotic arms.
In fact, Texas and the elevator.
It seems to have a lot of functions here on the train.
I remembered.
The bomb was brought into a train.
as a scraper shea egg the arms should have detected it and
would have allowed it on the only other person who knows the
coming going of the train is a conductor and he sure
wouldn't allow such a thing either wait that's me so we're
out of options sorry i personally hit you a little bit tails
i think we should wait and see what happens oh okay we wait
yeah i like i like the voice plays the most i think okay
Well, dig.
It opened.
It's hollow.
It's not a bomb at all.
You both really were onto something.
My, my.
That's one way to get the heart racing.
I'm completely relieved.
Oh, sorry.
That had a little bit too much emotion.
I'm completely relieved.
Sorry.
I had a little intonation in there.
My hunch was right.
Thankfully.
Ah, what's inside?
Oh, bling, bling!
Bedazzle chow!
Look at that sparkle and it's so heavy too!
Bling, bling, bling, bling, bling, bling, bling, bling,
bling, bling, bling.
The final secret to the Faberge Chao Egg is a chao covered
in gems!
That's a bedazzle chow!
It's Equisite It's Revolutionary And it's worth a lot of
money Is she drooling over a sparkly ornament?
I must admit It is stunning She said no one lived to tell
the Faberg Child Egg Secret I wonder why Why if the egg
wasn't a bomb Because they weren't as tough as us I don't
know Who cares?
What a precious treasure a beauty to behold maybe he
naturally died of old age and just kept the secret with them
no people keeping secrets no um as much fun as this has been
we should get out of here before we spot it good call let's
go is that it why not even have to interrogate them i mean
that's all No one seems to suspect anything.
And the security guard is back at their post.
Hope they subdued the drink coaster feeling okay.
Thank you both for your assistance.
That hunt was exactly the thrill I was seeking.
What about the murder?
Do we just not care about the murder anymore?
Sealing was strangely fun.
I prefer to never do it again.
Fucking pussy.
Now, Rouge.
Oh my god, what did she see?
She's completely absorbing that bedazzle.
Oh, she's still looking at the bedazzle, chow.
What is it, darling?
How about those blueprints?
Now that you're done with them, maybe we could take a look?
Well, I appreciate your assistance.
It's, as I said, finders, keepers.
I'll need them a little longer in case I missed any other
treasures.
But I promise to let you take a peek later.
I don't want to sound ungrateful, but I'm sure you get it,
sweetheart.
I hope she's talking to me and not the child.
You can't just add, sweetheart, to the end of a sentence to
make things better.
I don't think there's any reason of her.
She's more powerful than me.
Well, we'll get over your way for now, then.
We have a murder mystery to attend to.
You know, the one for Amy's birthday, guys.
You know.
Before you go, Shadow gave me and Rouge one of these.
He passed through earlier.
A key!
Let me unlock the door so you can continue forward.
You know, we've had a lot of people mention you, Rouge.
But we also have just as much suspicion about Shadow.
He's unpredictable.
That one.
Good luck to you.
The door is unlocked.
Both of you.
Stay safe.
Thanks again.
I like how, like, we're not even interrogating them.
We're just like, yep, they didn't do it.
The mystery continues.
They're just like, yep, all right.
Am I going to get one guide?
Tails, we must search the trash bin.
It's empty.
Oh!
Did I hear it all?
investigation even peeking in the trash see it's about
persistent stales my dad told me that when he met my mother
he would drive her to work two hours away every Tuesday with
flower from his garden she quickly agreed to a date and bro
that's fucking bro that's weird and when she arrived at the
restaurant she found two dozen roses waiting for her within
the year the two were married and it's about caring
dedication and persistence yes weather dose swads until she
says yes it's romance um that's very sweet but all that's in
the bin is a lollipop stick a lollipop stick yeah like the
leftover stick from a lollipop that's all there is Can't
believe I got one guide again.
Doki made up FPS VTube.
Is everything okay?
Do you need to bring you a flower?
It's a clue!
Tails!
You don't know that!
It's a clue!
Ooh, jackpot.
Oh, nice pinball!
Cheating, cheating, cheating.
Do you think I can cheat?
Park.
I like how we don't talk about Balin's Wonderland.
Wonderworld?
Hide, but...
Ready to get going?
Yeah, I am.
I am.
Let's find Shadow.
We're almost at the end of this murder mystery.
I can gamble?
Wait, I can gamble?
No!
You can play games?
The slots!
Take me back!
Oh no, no,
no, no, no, no, we couldn't gamble in front of the child.
We couldn't gamble in front of the child.
That was a good time to clean.
Any of my pockets.
I knew you weren't talking.
I knew exactly why you've been locking those doors.
Sorry to get a word in as you talk over me, man.
I have my reasons.
I...
No reason is convincing enough.
It's inconceivable.
What you did.
Hey, hey, hey, what's going on?
Hey, guys.
Hey.
Hmm.
I see you made it here, Tails.
But I didn't expect the Iron Chef as well we'll see what you
say when you microwave chili dogs delicious i'd like to know
why you've been locking doors throughout the train shadow
well seems amy already knows so ask her
i'm not saying a thing you know i will have to tell me why
now if you could leave me be i Have an appointment coming
up.
With what?
You're just a locksmith.
You don't have any other job.
Be immersive.
An appointment.
Yeah, who wants to meet him here?
Well, Doki made a FPS V-Tube.
It seems like Shadow isn't going to talk.
Let's do some investigating.
He won't talk until his lawyer's here.
All right, ready to find some answers to his?
Indubitably, my dear Doki made a FPS V-Tube.
All right.
What will make him talk?
Oh.
Maybe he has a date.
Wait, why is your computer?
Tails.
No.
Tails, I think we should check the trash.
Every trash bin has been empty, Doki made of FPS V2.
And you've been disappointed every time.
No, it'll be different!
This time!
That one guy can't be right for once.
There's no way.
That one guy can't be right for once in his life.
Are you going to get sad again?
There's nothing in the trash bin, Doki.
made out of FPSV too.
There's always something in the trash bin.
Alright, let's check the trash bin.
This time.
This is it.
This is the one guy.
What's this?
It's someone printed at the front page of a ticket website.
It's for the band Hot Honey.
Interesting.
Hot Honey is one of Amy's favorite bands.
Oh.
Oh my god, Shadow didn't get her a birthday present!
Let's add it to our inventory.
Shadow!
Are you sure this is just...
Trash?
That is Shadow.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it, Shadow.
What the fuck?
You got it last minute?
There's always success if you check the trash bin.
Crump of paper is added to your inventory.
I can't believe it, Shadow.
you didn't fucking you didn't fucking get her a birthday
present until you're on the train better late than never
they don't they told us about this interview the lounge has
a computer complete with internet access for casual browsing
how lovely seems convenient it is a shame to be on the
computer and missing those gorgeous views though I feel like
if you're using it's 8 p.m.
It's dark You must really need to use it Yes, I My life is
now as a tomato Playing Sonic the Hedgehog Oh, I thought
that was it Okay, well one of Wait, maybe the keys Hmm The
keys A keyring must be shadows The locksmith It's
interesting There's only two keys.
I figured a locksmith would have a bunch.
Wait, doesn't give away all my keys, though?
Want to take it?
Rough times.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Does that mean Amy's Latina?
Key ring is added to your inventory.
All right.
What else?
I'm going to check the door.
Oh, okay.
I thought like, uh, I thought like it would say something.
Can you open a wardrobe, please?
Wait, is there a reason I want me to do it?
What if something falls out?
Or worse, someone leaps out.
Or worse, it's a jump scare.
I just think you should do it.
All right, open a wardrobe.
Wait, Tails, yeah, do it.
Be a man.
Be a fox man.
All right.
Tough love.
I'll get it.
Today, you'll become a fox man, Tails.
Here goes nothing.
Ah!
Oh, just some sweaters.
See?
Not bad, huh?
Just dusty.
Boo!
Ah!
Sorry, I couldn't help it.
Yoki Meido, FPS VTuber.
I'm fragile.
Okay, clearly it wasn't...
Oh, wait, what's this?
Tells, you see this?
What was that?
A pullstring?
Yoki Meido, FPS VTuber.
What?
It's got to activate something.
There's a secret passage!
There's a full...
Okay, she didn't say that.
There's a full passageway back there.
Come on, we have to see where this leads.
He's curious.
This must mean something big.
Wait!
The library!
There's a secret passageway from the desk changes
everything!
Secret tunnel I don't believe it Wait, how the fuck does
that work?
Wait, wait, wait a minute Oh, does that...
Wait, wait a minute Wait.
How does...
Wait.
If the train is moving, like...
How does that work?
Like, wait, I'm a little confused now.
Yeah, but the train is moving, so like, how did the...
Alright, through the passageway before they spot us.
I'm confused.
My brain hurts now.
How the fuck, wait.
Wait, we need to add that to our inventory.
Hidden Paso Wait, I think I got the clues Yeah, it's time to
interrogate Shadow Ultimate life form It's time There's
nothing I can either help you There's nothing I can either
help Help with you I ask that you leave me be That stare So
cold Burr You know, we will get you We will get out of here
actually Don't keep made of FPS, B-Tube We certainly will
not Alright Can I take your aura?
I'll take you up on that coffee.
When I'm back in the dining car, I'll whip that right up.
Coffee on the train.
There's no better combination.
Hmm.
Some marshmallows will make it perfect.
Sure.
Because that's edgy.
Alright, let's actually interrogate him.
He likes it black.
Like his soul.
Shadow, we have questions for you.
For you three get out, I'm busy.
As I said, I have an appointment to attend to.
Sorry, but this is important.
Shadow, we question everyone on this train.
And every single person has mentioned running into you.
You've been locking every door in this train.
And...
And I know why.
Ah!
Pray tell why I was locking all the doors.
Time to reveal my hot tip.
Hope everyone ready for a scoop bound by yours truly.
We're ready.
According to the map, the next car is the conductor's car,
where Sonic was stationed.
This door right here in the lounge car.
is the only car that leads to the conductor's car.
So, Shadow was locking all the doors for one reason and one
reason alone.
To keep Sonic from escaping the conductor car.
So you think Shadow was trapping Sonic?
I sure do.
He locked the conductor's car, then locked all the others.
So one locked door wasn't suspicious.
I don't know, guys.
I think Amy's wrong, because it's never the first thing.
here conjecture you all get out and leave me be well my
source can back up who's my right source me source trust me
they remain anonymous but I think that source trust me
my source claims they never saw Sonic again after he went
into the conductor's car why Trust me, bro.
Because he was trapped and couldn't leave the conductor's
car.
Reckless speculation.
This is how you do your detective work, journalist.
Is the logic sound, though?
Was Shadow trapping?
Source, it's my birthday.
I'm right.
It's my birthday.
Happy birthday.
I'll play along and follow this train of logic, Amy.
Charlotte didn't lock the door to the Count Doctor's car?
Imprisoning Sonic?
Then how was Sonic found in the dining car?
Exactly.
I think Domain... Don't... Sorry.
Doki Mado FPS VTube and I can explain the car change,
however.
Doki Mado FPS VTube or what evidence do we have that shows
Sonic could have gotten to the dining car?
Well, obviously it's this.
Like, what else?
Like...
Or last week... Oh, yeah, it's this.
Oh, just cake.
Just get my thoughts in order.
Think.
Okay, I got it right.
It's think time.
Don't worry.
I'm just gonna play a little video game, guys.
Sorry, my mom said I can't pause this game.
It's okay.
Boop.
Oh, there's, like, no more, like, uh, oh, never mind.
Oh, wait, this is easier.
This is, like, easier than the fucking, uh, than the
straight line thing.
Why would this one be easier?
This is, like, literally endgame, isn't it?
Oh!
Guys, it's easier, I swear.
Doki Mado, FPS VTube, and I found a hidden passage in the
wardrobe.
That leads right to the library car.
What?
A secret passage?
Yes, it's literally right in front of us, Amy.
So someone could have used the passage, snuck through the
library car, walked past the distracted boys playing arcade,
and safely arrived at the dining car to eat all those chain
of dogs, and get a food coma?
Excellent work, Doki made of FPS B-Tube.
That just my fear.
Yeah, just a little bit, by the way.
The Shadow murdered Sonic in the conductor car, but then
thought the crime scene being so close to the station was
suspicious.
Shadow picked up Sonic, locked the door to the conductor car
on the way out, and dropped the body off at the dining car?
Happy birthday, it's my birthday.
Are you officially accusing Shadow of murder?
I am, but of course, this is just a theory.
A game theory.
I don't have any evidence to back this up other than my hot
scoop.
Seems Tails and I were more thorough than you.
The shadow's not going to talk.
Then I'll hear you once again.
The shadow traveled through the hidden passage and appeared
in the library car.
Then how did SBR and Vesper not see him?
Um, well, I suppose it would be hard to sneak around two
people.
Joki made an FPS VTuber.
Do you have any guesses?
Wait, what?
Okay.
Because...
Oh, Espio was reading!
Wait, it's both right.
Like, Espio was reading, and...
Oh, wait, Vector was with Knuckles.
Yeah.
I mean, it's...
They were...
Well, Vector was with Knuckles.
That's true.
Vector was with Knuckles, and would have seen Shadow enter
the...
a library car.
See?
Things are falling into place.
But what about SBO?
I believe SBO.
Yeah, it's an illusion of choice.
It was both right.
SBO reading library checks out.
That's what he told me too.
He's lying.
What?
What was that, Shadow?
When I completely obliterated Knuckles and Vector at that
whatever game, I left the saloon car.
What?
I spent so much time looking for Espio, but he was not
there.
He was not in the...
He was not in the... It was the poet!
Like, I believe you.
You're currently my number one suspect.
What?
It wasn't a butler.
Why were you even searching for SBO, huh?
Bum, bum, bum!
You must know I needed to give him a key.
As if why would Locksmith be giving away his keys?
Shadow has been giving away a lot of keys, actually.
Everyone but us seems to have one.
That's true.
Everyone's been able to unlock the next door for us.
I didn't know that.
Shadow's been passing out keys?
How could he?
I can't believe he's doing his job.
Perhaps Doki made out of FPS VTube and I can further
validate Shadow's claims.
Oh, it's a key ring.
It's also like the last thing.
We can do what?
Doki made out of FPS VTube.
What evidence supports Shadow's claim that he was getting?
Oh, wait, no.
Yeah.
He doesn't have a lot of keys left.
He just has two.
He is the key, man.
What else we'll be doing with all these keys?
good now to get my thoughts in order think oh shit okay all
right game break time to play my video games this is also
gonna be okay it's gonna be like the blast i think the blast
is actually easier than the the little uh the fire strike oh
sorry i got distracted no no don't no oh no this is actually
the worst i've ever done no oh okay i made it i've I barely
made it.
I barely made it.
Okay.
I still got it.
There's only one reason.
I have exactly two keys on that key.
Those were two keys Shadow meant to give Espion Factor.
No way.
Whoa.
One of his own key.
Can one of those be for him?
I have my own key on me.
likely story it's my birthday so let's say shadow's telling
the truth then what huh and shadow didn't murder sonic and
bring him to the dining car then what possible reason could
you have for locking all the doors hmm she's right her
theory is strong tales and I certainly haven't presented any
possibilities and shadow really instant in sonic's murder
it's because he didn't buy you a birthday gift he's a leech.
I think Doki made a FBSB too and I know exactly why Shadow
was locking all that doors.
Why does she keep including me too?
I'm just a butler slash microwave guy.
Huh?
Has everyone today given you a birthday present?
Yeah!
Yeah, Amy!
Almost everyone.
Yeah?
Everyone's been so sweet.
Oh.
Everyone.
He's just forgetful, Doki.
Hop off my goat.
How dare you say that about my Oshi?
The shadow of Sonic haven't given me anything yet.
But that's okay.
Just them being here isn't...
Oh my god, Amy, you're too nice.
Understood.
Thank you, Amy.
Doki made an FPS V2.
Uh, yes, Tails.
I have a theory.
Find a piece of evidence to support it.
We know Shadow walked through every train door, locking the
exit.
And he gave everyone stationed in the car a key.
Except for you, me, and Amy.
That's right.
The conductor gave her Amy her birthday key, not Shadow.
So why would he lock all the doors and not give us a key?
He wanted to keep us away.
Was Shadow locking all the doors to...
Keep us away.
Bum, bum, bum.
Nod us, Doki Mado, FPS VTube.
I'm making a leap here, but stick with me.
I think Shadow was trying to keep Amy away.
Oh my god, finally!
We knew this for like 20 minutes ago.
Holy shit.
Guys, any time now to solve that mystery about Sonic's
death.
Like...
Hmm...
Excuse me?
Shadow will never do that!
It's my birthday!
You know it's my birthday, right?
Don't you, Shadow?
Hmm...
How dare Don't keep me in a BSV tomb!
Show me evidence!
Huh?
Is Shadow trying to keep me awake?
Prove it!
You've been so thrilled or whatever.
Proof do you have?
Okay.
Tails and Shadow trying to keep just Amy away?
Why?
What if it showed what Shadow didn't want Amy to know that
he fucking bought this her birthday gift last minute on the
fucking train?
That feels right.
All right.
Gaming time.
I hope this is the last one.
Guys, all I'm saying, I have never lost.
a single one it doesn't matter if like i if i was like one
ring away from losing i still haven't lost though that
doesn't mean i lost chat that doesn't mean i lost it just
meant i did it there you go this has to be end game look at
all the blast
you went breathing through the trash what the is wrong with
you what is that.
We found this in the trash bin.
Next to it, I'll print her.
Hot Honey.
It's of a band's ticket website.
Tails.
Don't.
This is Hot Honey's website.
No way!
Hot Honey.
Oh no, they use Ticketmaster.
No.
Shadow, you're going to get scammed with all the fees.
Shadow.
Shadow, no.
Don't fucking fall for Ticketmaster.
It's the band I'm currently obsessed with.
Jeremy B is my current favorite.
All the members have B after their new name.
Isn't it cute?
I haven't gone to any other shows yet to see them though.
Their tickets are really hard to get.
They have to be really online at a specific time.
And they sell out.
They don't need a sponsorship.
a monopoly on fucking concert tickets like what do you mean
like they don't they don't need it because they're literally
the only place you can grab tickets unless you want to buy
scalpers but even then they're still fees okay anyway they
still admit this so the question becomes why was this paper
found in the train car shadow station in watch yourself fox
a situation becoming much clearer I don't know how Tails
figure things out so soon.
But I see where he's heading.
Bro, he's just playing the video game faster than me.
The printout of the hot honey band tickets website exists
because...
I don't know.
Fucking he was trying to buy tickets.
Like, where else would this go to?
Shadow's also a big hot...
Okay, yeah, that's another choice.
What?
Shadow, is this true?
Are you trying to get more cost tickets?
For my birthday!
Hmm.
I've done a poor job hiding the surprise, it seems.
Well, did you get it?
Yes, I'm trying to get you concert tickets for your
birthday.
Hmm.
Shadow!
She didn't even do it.
Like...
He didn't even do it, though.
He couldn't.
I used that printer earlier, and I found it difficult to
manage.
When logging on to the website, did you print the homepage
by accident?
you for the super chat thank you thank you yes that's
exactly what happened i'm not fantastic with computers
admittedly wait the ultimate life form is not a gamer what
he doesn't represent the people what but i thought i thought
you were supposed to be the gamer edge lord no
i can't believe this after i accused you a murder.
Spill everything, Shadow.
The cat's out of the bag.
I want to know everything.
I didn't get the tickets in me.
Like, fine.
The surprise is ruined anyway.
Probably our fault there.
Sorry, that's all the detective's job, I suppose.
When I arrived on the train, I realized everyone else had a
gift except for me.
Weird for my social status.
I immediately began brainstorming ideas and saw the
computer.
I remember Amy had never seen Hot Honey Live and looked it
up.
That's why I accidentally printed the home page.
The concert tickets weren't actually on sale, I realized,
but would be available soon.
Is that the appointment you keep speaking of?
The time you're able to actually buy the concert tickets?
Precisely.
I haven't purchased.
Yeah, I know.
I told you!
Bro!
Okay, I literally, if they let me talk, I would have
fucking, this murder party will be done in an hour.
Yeah.
And you had to keep Amy away while I waited behind tickets.
So I began locking all the doors.
But for the safety of everyone, I handed out keys so they
could get in and out.
Tell them not to let anyone through.
He's worried of his social status.
Like, look, it took him a lot of years to craft this social
status.
It didn't work.
Amy still managed to make here somehow.
It's because the conductor gave me this.
Yeah.
This key opens up any door on the train.
I've gone through every locked door with ease.
The plan's fatal flaw.
Journalist mode.
I should have guessed.
It's a well-known privilege.
Shadow, I...
Your gesture is so sweet.
And after I accused you, too...
How about this?
Let's buy the tickets later.
And to make it up to you, you can come with...
Wait, bro, it's...
What?
Why would she make it up for her?
Like, for her shadow.
It's her birthday.
She's the one that didn't even get the birthday present.
What?
Like, I don't understand.
Like, why?
He's the one that fucked up.
I don't know if...
Too late.
It's happening.
I can't wait.
A show of a lifetime.
Fine.
Does that mean she's paying for her own fucking tickets?
Happy birthday, Amy.
Thanks for buying my tickets.
I expect lots of pictures from the concert, you two.
Seems that Mr. Shadow's locked door has finally reached the
end.
I blame my source for all of this.
That was a hot tip at all.
They need me to believe Shadow was behind everything.
My credibility as a journalist report point it down the
drain.
I'm curious.
What is the source of your big scoop?
I'd like to know as well.
Sorry.
Strictly confidential.
Trust me, bro.
My credibility may be shot, but my principal must stay
intact.
I have a strong feeling to know who exactly is your source.
Is it Sonic?
Huh?
But we need to investigate one last area.
The conductor's car.
Oh, is it a conductor?
I'll come with you.
I'd love to know who's been dragging my name throughout the
mud.
I'll join you as well.
Now you see us through the end.
We're more than happy to have you both.
Doki made our FPS VTube.
I just say it, but I believe our investigation finally is
coming to the close.
Oh my God, we're going to figure it out.
It's being unclear.
Has it really?
I honestly think Sonic's in a coma.
Not like actual coma, but in the food coma from all the
chili dogs.
and this is.
We'll pin down Sonic's murder for good!
Right on then.
Let's do it!
Alright.
Nice.
Anything else?
Okay.
Let's finish this.
It's now or never!
The conductor's car.
It's really strong my evidence before I continue.
In my short time working on this train, I haven't visited a
conductor's car yet.
empty yeah where's the conductor wait where's yeah where's
the conductor that's odd i haven't seen him throughout the
train at all the best we saw him was when he left the dining
car something clearly happened here nothing we can't figure
out come on time to investigate whoa obviously the spilled
cup did this fall over when the train sped up did he have a
heart attack not sure wait what's it say on the mug a cup of
joe in your hand wife by your side paradise all right all
right we get it he loves his wife which wife okay not that
oh the arms when the arms broken wait what's this what's
this with someone playing darts that's not throwing dart
that's a blow wait it wasn't
someone brought this weapon onto the train that shouldn't be
possible how did he bring the how did he bring it
tails is right tails the train detects any weapons on a
passenger train before letting them abroad let's make note
of this load dart is adding your inventory okay there's no
way there's anything else in the trash I don't need yeah see
you're satisfied with finding clue here before huh I know
they say always check the trash bin, but I'm good.
I'll go on a high note.
See, I told you there's nothing in that trash bin.
This robot on has been completely torn off.
How creepy.
My arm is powerful.
It'd be tough to break out its grip.
A lot of people here have strength to tear this off, but the
question is why?
A confrontation definitely occurred in this room.
We should log this.
Aye, aye, sir.
Broken robot arm.
Yeah, I think we have enough clues.
Okay.
Amy!
I have the clues ready!
I'm ready to...
Oh, hey.
Oh.
I'm gonna skip.
Oh, next being for nasal medication.
Was that...
What?
Oh, the next ad I should have skipped that.
Okay, I was like, huh?
Perhaps too much detail.
Oh my god, there's him.
Look at him!
He looks so young.
Look at this doggo.
Alright, Amy.
I'm ready to solve the case.
You know this game is supposed to be two hours max?
Yeah.
Think you have enough eminence for me to call everyone here?
What do you think?
Jokey made a FPS V2.
Ready to solve this case?
Yes.
Hello, everyone.
This is our birthday, girl speaking.
Please report to the conductor car at once.
This is it.
Hello, everybody.
Sonic's not here because he's fucking dead.
Wonderful to have you all here.
Tails and I are ready to announce our primes.
I am.
Okay.
Oh, I don't need to do it.
Oh, okay.
I do.
With assistance from Doki Mado FPS B2.
Why is it Sonic?
Sonic showed up.
Huh?
Sonic?
Vector!
Real quick, can you come with me to get Sonic?
He must still be pretending to be dead, lazy bum.
Ready, let's go get him!
Alright, let's get it wrapped Sonic.
Let me tell you, darlings, this has been a delight.
A delight.
The air in here is so intense.
I love it.
I don't know.
My voice for Rouge keep fucking changing.
Nothing like the thrill of mystery.
The train has so many amenities.
I feel so catered to.
Admittedly, I've been having a lot of fun myself.
The amusement of a chase.
I see why you're a detective outside of this mystery SPL.
Wait, he's a detective?
I thought he was a ninja.
Yeah, and I love a good thrill, it seems.
But on this train, I am but a humble poet.
Is he a ninja detective?
I'd be willing to do an event like this again.
It says here, the train does escape rooms as well.
He's a detective ninja?
Bro, he can do anything.
Fucking nerd.
I love escape.
I fucking hate escape.
Count me in.
glad everyone's having a good time.
Maybe we can get rid of a train just to relax.
Oh, wait.
Maybe we could, sorry.
I was like, get rid of the train.
Maybe we can ride the train just to relax sometime.
Yeah, that'd be fun, too.
Ah!
Whoa!
Huh?
What in the world?
Oh, okay, wait.
That's Amy's voice.
Quick.
Oh, wait.
Where's Amy.
Oh my god.
He's dead.
He's not responding to us.
Sonic!
Is he hurt?
Guys, trust me, I checked his pulse.
He's definitely dead.
Um.
Is he hurt?
Why isn't he moving?
Sonic, Sonic, can you hear us?
he's banged up if there's a pulse it's weak oh my god he
actually has a pulse no fucking way set him down make sure
his head is propped up I'll help you hmm I knew one of you
would take this too far which one of you did this is Sonic
on my birthday no less does this have been one of us sorry
I'm like Ye-ha.
Y'all, could this have been one of us?
There's no one else here, Knuckles.
So I'll ask again.
Which one of you did this?
Is this a conductor?
Eggman.
Surprise, Eggman.
I can't believe it.
It was not a food coma.
This is inexcusable.
Sonic's hurt.
I'm going to expose the monster who did this.
Tails is not having it I thought Sonic could handle anything
But somehow he met his match Who murdered Who murdered
Sonic?
I'm gonna help you get the bottom of this I'm gonna help you
get the bottom of this Tails Absolutely Me too y'all Same
We're gonna figure out exactly what happened in this room
And punish the one responsible San Diego, thank you for the
Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you.
Don't kill her.
I'm not the killer.
Sonic!
I'm writing my wrong.
I must take down the murderer.
Tails, no key, made out of FPS V-tube.
I have a big question to ask.
Who in this room did this?
Who killed Sonic the Hedgehog?
Wait, what?
What?
Amy!
That can't be right.
Night of Tails and I can be the murderer.
That's right.
Wait, it's actually not Amy?
It's actually not Amy?
Oh my god.
Um, maybe it's...
It's the ninja detective.
Wait, it's the ninja detective because he was gone!
Espio, you were the one who murdered sonic weren't you i
didn't know such thing my young friend but if it's a battle
what's you wish i would love to discuss things let's discuss
what you're including espio we already talked about this
that man was reading you have nothing rotate right restating
espio's alibi will be would be helpful for everyone, I
think.
Espio was locked in the library car reading.
He only had access to the saloon car during the murder.
However, new evidence has come to light that needs to be
addressed.
Shadow said you weren't even there.
Tokimido, FPS, could you fill everyone in?
What did we find that brings in a question, Espio's alibi?
We discovered...
Vector's been active, protective.
We discovered a hidden passage!
Espio could laugh the library at any time.
B.S.
Tails and I find a hidden passage.
Bum, bum, bum.
Speed run to the lounge car.
Bum, bum.
In the lounge, the hidden passage exits behind the wardrobe.
I feel lucky we even found it.
Not only would Espio avoid any locked doors, oh, Vector is
his boyfriend.
But that would put him in the car, but just before this one.
You have no evidence I use any secret passage.
I answered.
Oh, the blue dirt, because he's a ninja!
I was reading the entire time.
Remember it.
It's true.
You didn't miss a question.
I think Doki made an FPS VTuber, and I can explain that too.
Doki made an FPS VTuber?
How did Espinel know everything in the train manual he was
reading?
Bro, I don't know.
A ninja like him.
Speed reads.
I don't know anything about ninjas, but I assume that's
true.
He's... Wait, he's fluent in 17 different languages?
And, bro, what the fuck?
How much perfect can you be?
Not perfect enough, because you got caught, bitch.
By a tomato.
What are you getting at?
You picked a random book from the shelf, and...
What the fuck is wrong with you, SBL?
That's way too much work.
Just normal ninja stuff.
Just to guarantee yourself, a clean...
alibi what that's absurd memorizing a whole book i know this
is a talented bunch but that seems like a lot i don't know
it is seen as plausible espio is particularly skilled
howdy y'all i've known espio for a long time he once spread
read a run spread read a book i was Just to spoil the ending
for me.
Oh my gosh.
That's what's up, man.
If I'm right.
And Espio quickly memorized.
Bro, he just hates him because he doesn't like that there's
somebody smarter than him.
But before entering the hidden passage, Espio is a kid that
your mom compares you to Bob.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Then Espio could have met Sonic in the Conductor Scar where
he was murdered.
Wait, but why was he in a dining car then?
Since we're only talking what is, let me throw something at
you.
How is I to know about a hidden passage?
It's hidden.
That's right.
Bro, stop defending him, bro.
The...
The chameleon bussy can't be that guy.
How many of us even have you even known it was there?
You said it yourself, kid.
You were lucky.
didn't even find the passes.
Doki made a PSB tube and I might not have the answer to...
They had the evidence to answer your question.
But we know someone who does.
Doki made a PSB tube.
Who here has evidence to prove Espio knew about the hidden
passage?
What?
Rouge the bat Rouge we need to see those blueprints
blueprints I didn't even get backseeded for this you so
blueprints whatever I already used it to sculpt for more
treasures came up cold you can have it blueprints are added
to my inventory there we go this right here is a blueprint
to the entire train could have easily used this to find the
hidden passage, because he got it first.
What makes you think I ever saw those blueprints?
Rouge had him, because you were in the library first!
Doki made a FBS B-Tube, do you have an answer for him?
How could SBFC know his blueprints?
He found them before Rouge did.
Wait, what?
Yeah, he found them before Rouge did.
Rouge, where did you find the blueprints?
Oh, um, the library car.
There's stuff with the shares.
I checked the saloon car first, then found the blueprints
after leaving.
So that means SBO had time to find the blueprints and
discover the hidden pass away!
In my theory, SBO looked at the blueprints and then used the
hidden passage to get to Sonic.
Within Amy's guidelines, the murderer can kill a single
participant however they choose.
The logistics are still vague, but Doki made up FPS V2 and I
have evidence on how Sonic was murdered.
I'm unsure how SPL cause Sonic, but Jokey made on FPS V2,
and I have evidence on how it was done.
Huh.
Oh, this is rich.
Pray tell.
If I murder Sonic, how did I do it?
Now, blow dart, you fucking ninja!
Now to farm my argument.
Come on, focus.
Oh, God.
Wait, this wasn't over.
guess it wasn't over I thought it was over but there's two
more rounds of this yeah there was actually more it's okay
we got this oh what first
this is bullshit oh my god my actual first dead that was
actually bullshit I can't believe it I can't believe I can't
believe that happened like why would I fucking be at the
springs oh my god I I can't believe it my perfect my perfect
world record my streak the blow dart was found here in the
conductor room I believe SPL used this to knock Sonic
unconscious.
Nice.
So you mean Sonic might just be knocked out?
Yes, he has a pulse.
Like, he's not fucking dead.
Like, I'm unsure.
He's more banged up than what a blow dart would do.
According to Amy's rules, a blow dart counts as a kill for
the murder mystery.
My theory, therefore, is plausible.
Plausible, you say.
Then why there's so many holes.
Like what, huh?
Like what?
Mr. Smartass?
You denied these allegations?
Of course I do.
Let me present the first fatal flaw.
If I knocked out Sonic in the conductor's car, then how was
Sonic found in the dining car?
That's a good point.
Tails was Vector!
Vector!
He's a muscle!
Oh, the cars and Espa didn't have a key.
He would have not to take the hidden passage back.
If he took the hidden passage back, he'd end up back in the
library.
Doki made a FPS V2, and I know another way it could have
been done.
Vector!
What piece of evidence do we need to take a closer look?
Um, we only have this.
I only have this, so, like, I don't know.
Does this mean anything?
like oh it's not the menu oh it's not the menu wait what
the map oh okay it was a process of elimination It was the
map.
The blueprints.
Yeah, what is my argument?
We're getting thick Doki made up.
Yes, me too.
What does the blueprint mean?
What?
What's the blueprint for?
I'm so confused.
What could a blueprint do?
It's just... Oh!
What?
I jumped.
I swear to God, I jumped.
Oh my God.
got think think dookie think what did it mean what did the
blueprint mean i actually don't know i'm so confused oh let
me grab this real fast in here okay nice we made it we just
have to not die nice there you go we just got it now oh my
god how did like the fucking level difficulty jump that
Alright, let's take a look.
What does this mean?
If Espio didn't take the secret passage to get to the dining
car, then what route did he get to Sonic there?
There's a path above the conductor car, and it goes all the
way to the dining car?
Oh!
I didn't even see that area.
I didn't even see that, too!
What the fuck?
How the fuck was I supposed to notice that?
Is this some sort of long attic?
He vented!
There's a hidden path in the ceiling that leads straight to
the dining car.
I can't believe it.
He fucking vented.
Perhaps you can access it.
Through the vent over there?
Oh!
The vent.
Of course.
That must be the entrance to the path.
Allow me...
Howdy, y'all.
Allow me to check it.
Pretty lady.
My word.
There is a path back there.
And a track, y'all.
Track?
How?
A track for the robot arms, I think, my lady, y'all.
This must be the path the arms took to move throughout the
train.
Just got this, but this game seems very forgiven.
The reason you're playing it, Jesus, honor, man.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So you're saying, so you're saying, I somehow fit with Sonic
in that bed and took him to the dining car.
Tells You're a smart kid.
I know you realize we both couldn't fit up there.
Espio's right.
This is feeling flimsy, Tails.
I need an answer.
My name is getting dragged around here.
This is pathetic, Tails.
Just because I know more languages than you doesn't mean you
have to be jealous.
How on earth would I get Sonic through that bend?
That has to be the arms at this rate.
Like, what else?
Can't do this.
Doki made a FPS VTube.
You can do this.
Objection!
Oh, think.
Wait, sorry.
I can't object.
Yeah, I'm still thinking.
Oh, my God.
There's still one more.
Okay, here we go.
Don't worry.
We got this.
Wee-oo-wee-oo-wee-wee-wee-wee.
Oh, wait, what?
How the fuck did I get hit?
What the fuck?
Okay, that scared me, actually.
Oh, there's...
too many things going on on my screen.
No!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, there's way too many things going on my screen right
now.
Oh, no, please, I need...
No!
How am I good?
Bro, what?
Okay, okay, we got this.
Bro, this is actually really...
This is the final countdown.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, this is bad.
This is bad.
It's over, it's so over.
It's so over.
No.
It's over.
There's no way.
I got knocked like.
How about not hitting any of these rings?
It's so over.
Oh my god.
Bro, this is actually a lot difficult than before.
Like, they're like not.
Not even generous with the rings.
That's like the worst part.
Oh.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
This is it.
No!
Okay.
68.
Just don't fuck it up.
Don't fuck it up, Doki.
Yes!
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
They were definitely not generous at all this time.
Everybody saw the broken robot arm on the ground, right?
Clearly a fight broke out here, and one of those robot arms
was a casualty!
But what if one of broken arms actually caught Sonic?
Knuckles said there's a track the robot arms use that
continues through the vent.
A robot arm could have grabbed Sonic, passed out from a blow
dart, and carried him to the dining car.
Could that be true?
Could you really do it, Espio?
Take a look at Sonic.
He's clearly banged up.
Could the fight happen between Sonic and the robot arms?
I can see that.
Those arms do look powerful.
Sonic doesn't fall easily.
But if he's woozy from a blow dart, the arms could have
gotten him.
Interesting theory, Tails.
But you have to admit, these are a lot of coincidences.
I might not be able to link everything directly to S.
yet but I found one inconsistency what kind of what kind of
inconsistency someone here received false information I
believe that information comes from SBO who received that
information wait what
Okay.
Oh, Amy.
Wait, what?
Amy, you see the hot scoop.
Did you not?
I think it's time you tell us where that scoop came.
Okay, I got a little confused with the way they worded that.
I was like, wait, I thought we already know it's Amy.
So, like, I was like, I got the way they worded that was so
confusing.
Tails, you're right.
Esma told me Shadow was locking doors to trap Sonic but we
found out Shadow was trying to keep me from discovering my
birthday surprise that scoop came from you Espio?
How dare you?
Word, they're going to do the Phoenix right?
Like breakdown.
No, of course not Amy.
Must have her misheard me.
You know her.
She's so ditsy.
Hee hee.
Misheard you?
Are you calling me stupid?
on my birthday.
Yes, I said, Sonic's going to get trapped with all these
locked doors.
I was just looking out for my fellow passenger safety.
I didn't blame shadow.
The ultimate life form.
I don't know, SBO.
What?
The evidence might not be airtight, but there's a lot being
thrown at you.
That makes sense.
I have to agree.
You want us to believe you're lazily reading the whole time.
You detective ninja know something.
languages while you were stationed in a room with a hidden
passage and now you're lying to me on my birthday of all
days he better have a really good birthday present
gaslighting works for sure look SBO is clearly not very good
at gaslighting and now you're lying I believe the murder
used the train's controls to move Sonic from the conductor
car to the dining car.
And lie to Amy, casting further blame on Shadow for no other
reason.
I can't believe it!
Espio wouldn't let Amy win on her birthday.
That is so fucked up.
It's literally her birthday.
When examining everyone's...
Wait, is Amy's birthday actually on April 4th?
When clearly stands out as the weakest.
I believe it's clear to everyone that it can only have been
one person.
God!
Professor Lee, it was you!
Espio!
This reminds me of a puzzle.
You were the one who murdered Sonic the Hedgehog!
They did the thing!
So...
Oh!
Hey guys Sonic you're okay Sonic and just as we saw the
mystery Espio was the murderer Right He's not okay Sonic
Espio jumps me in the conductor car Bro what the fuck is
this Dang it You got me A blow dart, though.
Really?
It's non-lethal poison.
You'll just be sleepy for a while.
Great, I could use a nap.
No, wait.
There's something important.
Espio left me there.
Bro, he's like not okay.
Someone get him to the hospital.
He is not okay.
Something important?
I need everyone to listen.
The trains.
What?
What's that?
Sonic, are you feeling alright?
Do you need to lie back?
Do you need to lie back down?
No.
We need to all get off this train.
We're not safe.
What?
When I...
Oh, it's Eggman's robots?
Oh!
I knew that.
I was just testing you guys.
I was just testing you guys on Sonic Lore.
Wait, is the conductor even a...
Is the conductor even real?
He was so excited to tell me all about the features of the
train.
But what he was telling me...
Was the conductor?
Was the conductor Eggman all along?
I had a bad feeling.
I had to see the power source.
The conductor hadn't even seen it.
When we took a look, we realized The train's powered by a
flicky A flicky?
The tiny animal?
There's only one person twisted enough to use a flicky as a
power source Dr. Eggman!
I told the conductor the train needed to be destroyed.
He refused.
The way the conductor was describing it Is more than simple.
It's the conductor's friend.
The train is his co-conviction.
conductor.
You're not serious.
Wait, where is the conductor?
They started telling me in that interview right as we saw
the flicky, I felt sting in my shoulder.
It was, wait then where the fuck was the conductor?
Wouldn't SBO see the conductor?
Ooh.
SBO left.
Lights in the room started to glow red.
Oh, evil, evil hands.
Oh, no.
Not the evil hands.
It is.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, okay.
There's a conductor.
What are you doing?
I knew something was wrong and stood up.
The arms came for me next.
I spin dashed through the right robot arm.
Sliced it off the rail it was on.
I'm amazed I was able to do any of that.
But another robot arm managed to grab me and pin me to the
floor.
Ah, wait, where did he go, though?
The conductor screamed as the arms approached him, but I was
hit quite a bit before it got to me.
Wait, it's not over?
Bro, we solved the mystery.
How much more?
I thought this was a simple murder mystery.
Oh, no.
Everyone have something to admit Now for the real Tutorials
over Alright Yes we know I murdered Sonic the Hedgehog Yeah
we already knew that man Guys we did it We finished the
tutorial This situation is kind of so serious Why would you
not tell us just tell us I thought that's how the murder
games work Darling You shoot someone with blow dart They die
Are you crazy?
It's just a make believe game No one should get hit with my
blow dart Okay she should have put that in the rules She's
literally like in a room filled with people That have like
killed things like And like are very competitive Like she
should literally clarify that In the TOS or something I was
just following the rules Yeah see Oh!
Oh, Eggman corrupted the rules.
It's laced with a non-lethal.
Are we sure it's non-lethal?
What is that?
It says, use this blow dart on Sonic Station in the Conduct.
I'm surprised Eggman actually made it non-lethal, you know?
Like, he could have easily got rid of him once and for all.
for choosing the Mirage Express.
What is this, instructions?
I was giving the blow dart along with that card.
It's signed, staff.
Who gave this to you?
Come to think of it.
One of the robotic arms handed it to me.
What picture do you allow it on a train?
What is the larger picture here?
Oh, who is Shrek?
I wonder.
Who is the main villain in Sonic the Universe?
Amy, oh my gosh.
Okay, I've been, if Tails said that, I would have been like,
What the fuck?
Who or what?
Doki Meadow.
FBS VTube.
Who do you think attacked Sonic and had an SBO to blow dart?
The train itself.
The conductor.
The conductor was secret Eggman.
Oh.
Okay.
Something wanted Sonic out of the picture and for good.
Wow.
So I think the train.
Oh, okay.
You won't even let me pick.
Oh.
Bro, it would have been a better plot twist if it was Eggman
disguised as the conductor and then he, like, pretended to
get caught.
They didn't even let me pick!
Oh, my God!
You got the 50-50 rod.
Oh, my God.
That would have been a better plot twist.
First, we learned the truth.
and now it's out to get us?
Yes, because it's a bad fucking train!
Once again, you keep saying the most ridiculous nonsense.
You're seriously convinced the train has been out to get us?
I don't know what the train's full of tense is.
AI.
I knew it.
Down with AI.
I fucking knew AI was gonna take over soon.
But the player's been tampering in our murder mystery
stream.
Train.
Hmm.
Come on and show yourself!
It's my birthday!
Amy!
And I don't need you messing with it!
Amy sitting on the wall with her hammer.
I'm with you, Amy.
This train can have it.
Come on, there's gotta be another way to get the train's
attention.
What was that?
Did I do it?
Oh, no, the train Anki.
The train is Anki, guys.
Whoa, what did you do?
Is that...
The conductor?
Wait, he's not even...
Okay, like, his mouth is...
His mouth isn't even, like, muffled.
Like, why are you...
Here, I can get him down.
Don't touch him!
Oh, he's...
The arms!
The arms don't want the conductor to leave.
He's the train wave!
I thought I was the train wave.
But it was the train.
That's the train wave!
Is the train talking?
Of course I can talk.
You fools were too distracted playing your little game to
figure it out.
We were right, weren't we?
What are you plotting?
I'm taking all of you to Eggman's base.
Where you will rot!
Eggman?
After I deliver your annoying party right to his egg
fortress.
Annoying!
She has a birthday pass!
The conductor and I will be free to laugh and play games.
Ride the open rails like we always planned.
No!
Oh, train wife!
What are you?
Enough!
The train's making up speed.
Everyone, everyone, grab something.
Which one of these buttons Turn the trains off?
Sonic!
Me and my train husband Say put until we arrive.
I am the yonder Train wife.
Goodbye.
Ah!
Wow!
Oh, wow.
I can't keep my footing.
Ah!
Am I going to meet A-man?
There's more?
What?
What are...
This was supposed to be a two-hour game.
A bunch of evidence has fallen out of my pocket.
My head tells Amy, Is anyone here?
Hello?
I thought this game would end in two hours.
That's why I picked it.
No need to yell, but...
Sonic?
I'm so sorry.
Are you okay?
Hanging in there.
It seems the train arms threw us back in the dining car.
That was the tutorial.
Now the real game starts.
everyone else great question i like how like in the end we
actually have like i was like it's funny that the sonic game
doesn't have a lot of sonic and then the game in the end was
like no no no obligatory sonic here but for now are you all
right sonic the hedgehog asking about me i'm special i feel
terrible i'm doing amazing you know what he should know i'm
he should not know that i have weakness inside me Amazing,
huh?
He might have to share a bit of that enthusiasm with me.
Am I over?
Wait, it's okay.
Look, look, see?
He's giving me a thumbs up.
See?
He thinks I'm cool now.
Let's get our barons to take a look around.
Good idea.
Leap the way.
Alright, wait, what the fuck?
The arms are still, like, working?
Okay.
How do we get out?
That yellow glow is chilling.
I miss when just showing us the weather.
Well, that's better than the yellow glow.
Oh, it's the Eggman!
Hello?
Anyone here?
Why is no one responding to me?
I missed the yellow glow already.
You got some nerve showing up here, Egghead.
You spiky blue pest.
You finally, Jim Carrey, oh my god, Jim Carrey.
Seems you finally taking passage on one of my passenger
trains.
You own this train?
I mean, obviously he created this train.
Who the heck are you?
Don't talk to me.
You're not famous enough.
Talk to me when you have 10,000 subscribers.
They certainly didn't talk about you in my interview.
My involvement isn't well known.
Civilian.
Alrighty then.
The infrastructure in your towns just wasn't cutting it.
What if I were to build Igmanland?
These problems would need to be sorting out.
So I courageously got involved.
I converted some cargo trains into...
Wait, so he was helping.
What?
He was helping the economy.
For the sake of the public, it's just more useful for future
schemes.
Oh my god, he's so nice.
He helped the city's economy by fixing the public
transportation.
Let me guess another death egg, Dr. Predictable.
The people fear giant spears.
It's science.
Let's cut to a chase.
We're our friends.
Judging by my security cameras, your pathetic friends are
all locked in the cars.
They were stationed in.
Wait, how does he know?
Wait, what?
Oh yeah, he was controlling.
Controlling our fucking murder mystery.
Seems you managed to make the train quite upset.
Do you not know this was happening?
heavens no i'm only now getting caught up i'm too far busy
to notice what a passenger train is up to you see the
capability is normally very basic just kill sonic the
hedgehog that's so cute it's just like the first sonic game
but for a luxury train i want to be sure things ran without
my supervision and report to me if any of you happened to be
aboard intellectual thought.
It's extraordinary.
A feat only accomplished by my genius, because he has a
doctorate.
So this confirms it.
The train really is sentient.
Except this to say, your capture is innovative.
You are not a train that desires nothing more than to
deliver you all to me.
See, I got thinking.
I might need it to manufacture motivation beyond
programming.
So I made him fall in love with the conductor.
It's good for productivity.
So I instituted a bounty upon my army.
First to capture your pathetic creature gets a generous
award.
The train wants to deliver us to Eggman for a reward?
Most of my robots ask for something simple.
Like my autograph.
Or whatever.
A highly intelligent train.
They may ask for something more interesting.
The train wants to be hot!
I can see it.
As much as I like to reward programs.
Are you done blabbering, Doc?
They want to, the train want to be put in like a hot Android
dog wife thing.
And so like, the train can kiss the conductor and be...
Like, not just train wife, but, like, regular wife, you
know?
You can never just win silently, can you?
When you're dragged to my base, you'll regret the day you
ever crossed me, Hedgehog.
I already do.
Get lost!
Ciao.
He always knows how to get under him.
Why is he blushing?
Why the fuck is he sorry?
I just got off the call of my boyfriend Eggman.
This is tough.
The train has a motivation in being made by Eggman.
It's no doubt powerful.
Not to mention we're all separated.
What am I supposed to think?
The train purposely had Sonic knocked out so it could
deliver us to Eggman.
This whole time we were all in danger.
And I went along with it.
Sonic was really hurt.
That conductor's been captured.
Should I have been more assertive early?
Bro, what would you do?
What would you have done?
You literally, you are nothing in this train.
Like, I didn't try hard.
No, I tried as hard as I can.
I'm just a fucking regular Sonic OC.
They're the same answer!
Am I a fault here?
Okay, yeah, I knew Sonic.
Okay, that was sort of my fault.
I knew Sonic was hurt all the time.
Hey.
I can tell the situation's getting to you.
Oh, yeah, sorry.
I get it.
The road's getting tough.
It's easy to question the decisions I got you here.
But when negative thoughts hit you, Don't be sad.
Sonic, this is terrible advice.
But when negative thoughts hit you, let it pass.
Just stop being sad.
Fucking hells.
Depression is safe.
Thank you, Sonic.
I need you here helping me think this through before I do
something rash.
I can't believe it.
Sonic cured my depression.
See, I'm one of those Leap before you think kind of guys.
Have you tried not being depressed?
Thanks, Sonic!
Now I will never be depressed!
Okay, you're right.
Let's keep moving and make things right.
I'm cured.
Thank you, Sonic, for telling me Breathe.
Okay.
Alright.
We gotta get to the conductor's car before the train
arrives.
is that egg of his face you should switch your therapist out
for sonic at the youtube chat thank you guys i don't need to
go to therapy anymore sonic told me to stop being sad i'm
fucking cured the toys have been heavily fortified how do we
get through just use your fucking spin dash
believe in yourself no matter the ass believe believe it i
know you have what it it takes to figure it out.
The entire day, Tails and I have been asking yourselves,
what would Sonic do?
So what would you do?
What would I do?
Will I speed through head on and rescue my friends?
By any means necessary.
I knew it!
Spin Dash!
Woo!
Did I do it?
Oh, I have to fucking...
I knew it!
One big wind-up Sonic Spin Dash was fast enough to get that
door open.
Now that's the rose killer.
Nothing can stop us.
Better hold on to your pants.
I don't think we'll be getting another break after this.
Ready to go?
Yes.
Let's do it.
Got the fucking spin dash every fucking room?
To the conductor car.
The end of this mystery.
Does it go through every fucking room?
Let's see.
Because then I'd be... Oh, what the fuck?
Okay, real game.
Alright, our friends are locked in the cars up ahead.
In my last adventure, maxing out my ring count gave me an
extra boost of speed.
My grand grab enough rings.
I should be fast enough to burst through the next door too.
Oh my god, it's full screen time.
Let's do this.
The sprites are so cool.
I love the sprites for this.
Let's see.
Mew!
Okay guys, okay, this is not looking so good.
You know what?
Maybe we aren't gonna be saving our...
No!
Okay, there's no way.
They're gonna be like super generous with these.
Oh, I just...
Oh, shit.
Just wait till I see Eggman, y'all.
I'm gonna clobber him.
We gotta deal with the train first.
Come on, let's go.
Hmm.
Is Knuckles gonna join me?
Wait, Knuckles is not even gonna join me.
Guys, exact rings.
How does she do it?
I knew I just needed exact rings.
Oh, no.
It's like each level is like each of the mechanics they
introduce.
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, this is rough.
This is so rough.
No, I just got it, too.
Oh, my god.
Okay, I'm fucking doing it.
All right, I hope it doesn't make me restart.
You all came for us.
Of course, but let's move.
The train wants to take us prisoner and earn a reward.
My reward is to get off this stupid train.
Let's go.
Alright.
I'll get to 60.
Is this the one where it's like the missile?
Or is it still the spinny thing?
Oh, nothing is popping up.
I don't like that.
Why is nothing popping up?
Okay.
Okay, we got it.
We just got it.
I'm getting better.
Spin dash!
Sonic.
It's about time.
I thought you were supposed to be fast, Sonic.
Okay, why don't you save yourself, fucking bitch?
Okay, we got a movie too, ready?
Always.
Let's boogie!
Alright.
Oh, it's just a...
Okay, these one I'm not as scared.
Because, like, it's just, like, the missile, and I can dodge
those.
Like, I just need to...
I just need to...
She didn't even say thank you!
She was just like, where were you?
fucking rude man i literally saved her ass oh exactly but it
doesn't matter because i am an overachiever okay this one
was really easy all right they locked amy and tails in the
conductor car say no more let's go all right last one this
is the one where stuff will start disappearing right Missed
the fucking...
Oh, it's 55!
They gave me less of a challenge!
Nice.
Okay.
55.
Okay, I was gonna be so scared that I, like, that was, like,
last.
That should be it.
Spin dash!
Sonic!
Sonic, you're here!
Is this a way to treat?
This is no way to treat that birthday, gal.
You're right.
I'm gonna stop this train.
I'm ready to stop this train.
to finish this.
Nice.
Is that it?
Did I?
Did I did it?
Did I do it?
Excellent work trapping these pests.
Now hurry to me.
I must properly dispose them to begin my plans.
For Igmat Latte!
Wait, he just wants to build an amusement park?
Like, what's so bad about that?
And probably another death?
Okay, maybe that's pretty bad.
Deathig!
Don't teleport us to the, uh, yeah, maybe not tell, yeah,
and don't teleport us to the future.
Teleport you all to the future when I've already ruled the
planet?
Sure, I'll do that.
Whatever.
Shut it, Eggman!
Don't disappoint me, train.
Hurry it!
Hurry it up.
I will not fail.
My wish will be granted.
your wish oh yeah you mean the bounty I don't care what you
call it just bring me those overgrown mamas but he's a
mammal too wait what that egg man yes cuz the conductor is a
fucking dog guys don't be freaks the conductor is a dog I
must Get my wish.
I will not fail.
This is it, everyone.
Get ready.
We're taking this thing down.
There's more?
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, my God.
Oh, shit.
He has arms now.
I mean, he always had arms.
We're good.
It's okay.
We're almost at 65.
It's basically like that one where the fucking meteors were
dropping.
Except now there's their arms.
Woo!
None of you could possibly understand.
We promised to be together our whole lives.
How could he lead like it was nothing?
I was literally his train wife.
What do you mean?
The conductor?
He's retiring.
You just have to accept that.
my wish will keep us together forever oh friends sure they
were cowards you can't force someone to be friends with you
that's messed up shut up just shut up we're Really, really
good friends.
Alright, let's...
Let's grab some more rings.
Woo!
Very close to...
Wee!
Oh, shit, okay.
Alright, we're done here.
Yeah!
Eggman, Eggman, can you hear me?
My wish, my wish, my wish.
Make the conductor never...
Oh my god, that is so sad, bro.
Make the conductor...
Bro, just download yourself to a phone.
Everybody has phones.
Never leave me.
Let us be friends.
Forever.
The kind of...
The kind of friends.
Who would never leave each other.
Why would he betray me?
Bro, that's sad, bro.
Alright, here we go.
And they were just roommates, Chad.
They were just roommates, guys.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh no.
We're not getting a lot of rings.
I hope I didn't miss a lot.
Oh, fuck, I looked at Chad!
Okay.
This is it.
Oh, I just made it.
Oh, thank God.
Conductor!
You promised me.
You promised!
Let him speak unhand him.
Hey, guys.
It was great that you guys helped along, too, guys.
Train, stop this.
I told you we'll be each other forever.
I was a...
I was a much younger man.
I'm getting old.
getting tired.
I can't keep up with you anymore.
Excuses.
How dare you abandon me?
I'll be lonely.
So lonely.
Why must you insist learning this upon me?
Whoa!
No, stop.
What are you doing here?
To me.
Whoa!
don't make me do this oh we have to rescue the conductor if
we ever want to stop this train robot this is too far this
is too far that's fucked up what the fuck bro what is the
train gonna fucking kill me like like oh he's just going
like the floors below me okay i thought it was like oh okay
never mind never mind things got more intense oh yep things
are whoa things are whoa oh there's a lot of things going on
on my screen that's okay i made it all right nice i hit the
train oh my gosh is this a three hit thing no okay thank god
oh there he is there's the bird Bro, it's powered by one
fucking bird.
Those are some strong fucking legs.
A flicky.
This is just like the lore card.
When my ex-best friend left detective work to join Dr.
Eggman.
So this really is a bad, bad egg.
The stakes are rising every second, huh?
A toky bird.
We gotta save him, y'all.
Howdy.
On it.
Let's show our full power.
Oh, guys, guys.
Are you guys going to help out?
Guys.
No?
All right.
Let's do this.
By myself.
Let's go.
You know, I assumed that he was going to, like, you know,
like, my, you know, my team would want to help me with, you
know, killing the train.
All right.
Let's see.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Thank God.
Oh.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, thank God, okay, I still have just enough rings.
Sonic's got this.
Is this three hit?
Like the usual Sonic games?
Just to be delivered to Eggman already?
What about my happiness?
Your happiness comes at expense of others.
That's called being selfish.
Whoa!
Me?
Selfish?
How?
How dare you?
Oh no, one more hit.
That's me three hits, just like Mario.
I can't believe I said that for a Sega game.
Okay.
Let's go.
Oh my god, there's so many things going on my screen.
Nice.
Okay.
A hundred!
okay okay I didn't realize okay guys guys I don't know I
didn't realize no not enough rings no don't don't make me
okay it's still a hundred oh thank god I was gonna be like
that's gonna be it so I fucking oh my god this one's so hard
This one's a why is like the last one always has like a huge
difficulty spike Is it that before too?
Okay, no I couldn't I couldn't see there's two no guys.
I don't guess I don't know The last one always has like the
most insane difficulty spike Oh my god Okay, here you go.
I'm gonna do this.
Guys, hey, hey, hey.
Do you remember I have a team that's just watching me?
Oh, man.
What a great team.
What happened to SPO?
The one that knows...
That's the ninja detective that knows 17 languages.
Why isn't he helping me?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, please don't hit.
Oh, I did it.
Okay, there you go.
Prokiemer tip.
Avoid the spike.
Thanks, Gwen.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
He's tired now.
Oh, now you're tired.
You've been in that train for a very long time.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Wait, what does he eat?
It's over.
How does he even eat and drink water?
pay for ruining my birthday it's as simple as that crusader
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you oh that's
so cute the little heart where's my arms where's my arms
floating knife stab stab okay nice
oh that's cute oh my god my hero
The train is slowing down.
Great hit, Amy.
It was pretty great, wasn't it?
That's what you get when you mess with my special day.
I just couldn't bear to see you go.
I'm sorry for that, Trappa.
Oh, no, he's gonna cry.
I think our work here is oh my god he's so heartless now
let's get off this thing train wife no train wife give train
wife i'll kiss thank you goodbye my friend i may be jesus
fuck man i may be leaving the rails i'll assure you I'll
never forgive or forget our time together.
Jesus fucked up.
Trainwife.
What does real wife have?
What does landwife have that trainwife does it?
Huh?
Trainwife has like 200 plus arms.
That is?
Oh, there you go.
We did it!
Oh, we did it!
You know what they say?
about 200 plus arms.
Well, I say, I've never been on a train like that before.
This universe has a unique way of doing things.
Watch your step.
It's over.
The mystery of Sonic the Hedgehog's murder is officially
over.
Maybe next birthday.
We just asked Vanilla to make dinner.
Ye-ha.
Oh, you don't love parties?
We're by the end, someone tries to kill you?
I think I'm going to miss this group.
Unhinge, way of thinking.
Oh, God, no wonder.
Yeah, train wife.
Honey, you're late.
I've been waiting here for out.
Oh, I'm sorry, train wife.
He made the right choice.
Yeah.
Sorry, bro.
You'll honestly never believe what happened.
Bro, what the?
That's so fucked up.
He's like, just, it's just like a story to him.
It's just...
Like, by the way, like, trade wife was like, now my trade
husband.
And then he's like, oh, honey.
Let me tell you.
about this crazy story I had with a fucking train.
It was everything for train wife, but the train was just an
afterthought.
So I won't even try.
Paha, paha, paha.
I'm just glad you're here.
Quick, we'll leave for Spagonia in the morning.
you need to pack.
Oh, pack faster than the wind.
I need this vacation.
Something terrible.
What?
I need this vacation.
Something terrible.
Wait.
I need this vacation.
Something.
Wait, does this, like, make sense?
This is...
Oh, okay.
I can't.
What does that fucking mean?
It's ink.
Oh, it's an idiom?
Oh, it's old man.
talk i was just like what the fuck is a sentence sorry for
those who actually knew what that means that means you're
old and i need and i need you home happy first day of
retirement dear seems the conductor is more than ready to
begin his retirement hey honey let me tell you what happened
with my crazy train x thank you super chat guen thank you
thank you i'm happy for them both
An old friend, I think.
Well, they're a cutie.
That's for sure.
Cheap, cheap, cheap.
Seem that, Flicky found a friend.
I hate that name.
Like, I'm sorry, but Flicky is such a terrible fucking name.
It just sounds so bad.
Great job.
Saving that little guy, SBO.
this was the least i could do sonic everyone i sincerely
apologize for the trouble i caused don't be you're just
following what you thought was a game it's hard to know what
i would have done in the same situation i wouldn't have hit
someone with i wouldn't have hit someone with blow dart
seriously a dart it would have been hard to get close to
your otherwise mr speed of sound Regardless, I am sorry.
We're cool.
And now that we're all safe, it was fun.
This group has a wild idea of fun.
Boy, I am starving.
I forgot we never ate.
With, hey y'all, with all that clatter, I completely forgot
I was hungry.
Me too.
I was distracted playing detective.
They even eat?
They never even eaten at all.
If only you have seen me, Sonic, I was finding clues,
presenting evidence, poking holes, and alibis.
Sonic, wait, where did he go?
Oh, is it chili dog time?
Everyone, guess what?
Chili dogs!
What?
I was lied to.
Where the fuck is my chili dogs?
This station has a bakery.
And look what I bought.
A bird...
Wait, what?
That was so fast.
how did they somehow have amy's face on a cake at a nearby
bakery a birthday cake
to the confident unshakable and radiant amy rose to an
adventure of a birthday darling a memorable party i don't
have pants i'm sorry a memorable party Every year.
Howdy to a fun birthday.
A ride.
A ride from start to finish.
Just like my dark soul.
May our friendship grow stronger each celebration.
I admire your tenacity.
May you never lose your vivacity.
I don't know.
Happy birthday to Amy.
And her sparkling personality.
Happy birthday!
I'm not smart to know if personacity is a word.
Me too.
Because I'm you.
We love you, Amy!
Happy birthday!
Ah!
You guys!
We almost got murdered by a lonely train!
But, but!
I like how to do this all in front of the train corpse.
Like, that's, like, the most fucked up thing for me.
Like, there's a fucking corpse of a train.
there and they're just like yay I wouldn't trade these
adventures for anything never in a minute like did they not
feel anything like that train was like fucking depressed but
like Sonic says just stop being sad never in a million years
you guys won't ever leave me right wouldn't dream of it now
let's have some cake yes please dig in everyone yeah i hope
it's chocolate hmm
it's her what is this let's go dad oh that's so that train's
never making it here is it or but prepare the bath let's go
dad the happy rubber duck or the ankle the happy be robot
rubber duck or the angry one angry sour choice your evilness
shut it that's so cute let's go dad and that's my story of
when i met sonic and his friends entangled in their lives
for a moment and then back to things as they were.
Cities realized Eggman was running the train station and
fought back to seize control.
Everything's squeaky clean now.
As for me, I quit my job.
Wait, no.
Okay, if I stuck with a gig, that means train wife is mine.
Do I keep my minimum wage train job for train wife?
Or, like, or quit, guys.
Stick with it?
I could have train wife.
I can have my own train wife.
Okay, and then.
One millionth in the lottery.
Okay, one millionth.
And after all that, I managed to fly.
Why would I already did that on stream?
Manage to fly to space.
Yeah, that's just been my life.
Guys, I got my own train wife.
Now I'm affluening to me.
Oh my god.
Holy fuck.
That was five hours.
Oh my god.
It's not even April Fool's for East Coast anymore.
And then everybody stood up and clapped.
We did it!
Yeah!
That was fun though.
I'm really happy to actually finally try out this game from
start to finish.
I've always wondered what this game, I mean obviously it was
about the murder of Sonic the Hedgehog, but like I was
always wondered like what was this April Fool's game.
That was really fun.
I really had a lot of fun though.
I haven't voiced acted like this in a while.
Me and my four, like me and my three voices that I can do.
you know But I'll say thank you to the official Sonic
channel for For drop I don't even know if that's the
official Sonic channel if it was I like to say thank you to
the Sonic the head Was that even the was that the official
Sonic the hedgehog channel?
If it was it is oh my god I'll say thank you to the official
Sonic the hedgehog channel for watching me play this game um
but that was really fun i had i honestly had oh my gosh that
is you type so long that the fucking alert got cut off oh my
god but yeah huge shout out to sonic for watching me play
sonic the hedgehog the murder of sonic the hedgehog i'm all
fun i'm all fun um the artwork was like like super fucking
cute too and um it was just fun to like do an april fluid
stream um it might not be like super elaborate and i was
just a tomato but i hope you guys had a fun time watching
this with me is there an after credit scene there is okay
we'll stay guys apparently i don't know i might have got one
guide i don't know i could i can easily get one guide guys
thank you with super chat thank you thank you the biggest
prank was how conductor mama converted me to the Sonic
Phantom.
I understand now.
Thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
I'm just saying, I understand why the conductor chose land
wife over train wife.
I understand now.
That's so fucked up.
The train wife was like putting their entire soul into like
how much they love conductor as a friend.
As a really good roommates, you know?
And then the conductor was like, Oh my god, real wife.
Let me tell you about this.
Oh my god, real wife.
It was such a funny day.
I'm just like, what?
That was such a funny day, real wife.
Oh my god.
Ha ha ha.
Poor train.
Poor fucking train.
So someone was like, I'd make the same choice it was so fun
shout out to um america the sega team in america for making
this um i also thought it was made by um the jp team so um
i'm glad the the sonic the official sonic channel actually
fact checked me and was like i was like no it was actually
america and i was like oh my god fuck yeah america yeah
Like, assume it was Japan, because they always go super all
out when it comes, uh, when it comes to, like, April Fool's
shit, because they are, like, super dedicated to April.
I don't, I, I, honestly, I'm like, I got one guide.
There was no fucking, I got one guide.
There was no extra credit scene.
I can't believe it.
Like, I got fucking one guide as always.
God damn it.
Um, anyway, anyway, I had a great time with everybody.
I am gonna call it here tomorrow.
Sadly, for those who didn't read Twitter, I will be
canceling tomorrow's stream because I will be like, I want
to be like working and stuff tomorrow to because there's
been, I need to like stabilize.
I've been going way too fast in my career.
So tomorrow, I will be like working on stabilizing myself
and making sure to like look through everything to make sure
that like restructuring how things are done.
behind the scenes so like we don't like miss out on things
so that's why tomorrow there will not be a stream tomorrow
I'll pin that on the schedule waiting room so like if people
were like where's the stream and then they look at the
schedule they'll be like there's no stream but yes everybody
I hope you guys had a great time and I hope you guys had a
great April Fool's with everybody that's been doing April
Fool's stuff I hope you guys had a fun time watching as
always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and
around to get that blood flowing and if you sail for me head
to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody bye guys bye